Yes and we launch and we're live.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by lumosity.com
Lumosity is essentially a gym for your brain,
gives you a bunch of really cool exercises to stimulate your mind and you can
set them up.
He had that breathing heavy man breathing.
That's John Hackleman and breathing into the microphone like a man.
We've had that issue before.
Eddie Bravo,
right?
Remember 80 Bravo fucking mugged that thing.
lumosity.com like I said,
an online gym essentially for your brain and how appropriate that we have the
pit master here when you're talking about online gyms and we're actually in an
area very,
very near where the original pit was.
This historical shit.
It brings back memories.
I'm sure Lumosity is.
Brain Games are designed by top scientist to train the mental processes and over
time you can track your progress online and compare yourself to other people.
Don't compare yourself to me.
You're going to feel sad.
I feel sad as fuck.
Fucking not as good at these brain games.
Plus he mosque Lumosity only takes a few minutes each day.
You can play from anywhere you computer,
iPad,
iPhone with the free Lumosity app so you can have fun,
work your brain and make Lumosity part of your everyday routine.
It's very um,
flexible.
When you go to Lumosity,
you can,
uh,
when you click on the get started now button,
you start screwing around with it.
And as you see,
when you start doing it,
go to lumosity.com forward slash Joe.
Um,
when you start entering in like what you're looking to,
uh,
to accomplish,
it's,
it's very fascinating because there's so many different aspects that they have
designed these games for like memory,
recalling the location of objects,
remembering names after the first introduction,
which a lot of people are super fucking bad at.
And attention,
maintaining,
focus on important tasks,
improving productivity,
like all these different things you're trying to improve and they've got these
games that are designed to try to meet those challenges and uh,
get your brain in shape.
I find it really fun and fascinating and a,
you could check out my special Lumosity page to get started.
Go Lou lumosity.com/joe Click the start training button.
And then start playing your first game.
That's lumosity.com/joe.
We're also brought to you by on at.com.
That's o.
N N.
I t.
Um,
if you haven't been there before on it ha is essentially what we like to call it
human optimization website.
We're just trying,
and I can only say that so many times in a row before.
I don't even like hearing to come on out my own mouth.
[inaudible] folks,
these things have to get done.
There's no other way to say it.
We have a bunch of really cool shit though.
If you've never been there before,
you'll enjoy it.
Um,
if you're into strength and conditioning,
we have,
uh,
a bit,
basically anything you could ever need like kettle bells,
battle ropes,
weight vest,
steel maces,
steel clubs,
ab wheels or things along those lines.
And we also have artistic ones.
We have these Zombie Bells and these primal bells that we,
um,
had made by this sculptors named Steven Shubin junior and he's a bad
motherfucker and made some cool ass kettlebells,
the chimpanzee ones,
the gorilla ones,
the great apes.
He should make a pit one with a skull pit version.
Yeah,
like you're a,
that's not a bad idea.
You could totally get something like that done.
Well,
if you do it though,
the key is like the,
one of the things that's real important,
like when we have these design is to make sure that they're actually balanced.
They don't just look really cool,
but they're not wacky.
They're not like they're,
they're,
one of the things about a Kettlebell is that it's a uniform in its movements.
Like when you're swinging that kettle bell and you're controlling it,
it's very balanced.
You don't want it like waited 60% to one side and 40% to another and they'd be
all wonky.
So we worked very hard to make sure that these kettle bells are 3d balanced so
they don't just look cool.
The design actually is functional.
The Zombie Bells,
the the my favorite,
the primal bells,
all that stuff.
Strength and conditioning equipment,
supplements,
exercise,
DVDs,
all shit to improve the quality of the functionality of your body.
So get there and use the codeword Rogan and save yourself 10% off any in all
supplements.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
without further ado,
okay,
we want to just get popping right away.
John motherfucking Hackleman is here.
Cue The music,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
I've been around martial arts since I was a little kid and uh,
I have always loved to talk to guys like you that have not just been around
martial arts but come from a traditional martial arts background.
You were there for the birth of MMA.
You know,
you're still walking around did g pants and you still sport his fanny pack.
You don't give a fuck.
And you,
you've been around for a long time,
man.
You've been around through uh,
the,
the whole birthplace of MMA and trained arguably one of the greatest fighters in
the history of the game and chocolate,
Dell.
I mean,
we can argue,
impossible to argue right in.
Arguably,
I should have said no.
I mean top all,
one of the all time,
most exciting guys to watch ever,
ever,
ever.
And he was always like that.
And you were there through his entire ride,
man,
from day one.
Yeah.
I remember you were there when he fought,
was it?
No.
[inaudible] Hernandez.
Is that the guy that the cat's name that was a the boxer guy.
Yeah,
and they came up to chuck backstage and,
and John and John Perretti told chuck not to shoot on him because he found out
chuck was a wrestler.
I told him if he wants to work for the UFC,
you got to have to stand up and bang.
They stood up and banged all right.
He's tickled.
He stood up and bagged a lot.
Yeah,
we've been telling that guy.
Yes,
they do that.
So hilarious.
It's like you didn't have to tell him that he was going to do that anyway.
No,
he's,
he's chuck fucking Lidl.
I actually,
towards the end of his career,
I begged him not to so much and he still wouldn't,
he would not stop banging.
He Bang to the end.
Yeah,
he certainly did.
And it was,
he's talked about it before too,
that he just like would hit a guy and he'd know he had him hurt and it's just
killer instinct.
We just take over and he couldn't help it.
He couldn't help it.
He would,
he would,
we would spend hours and hours and hours with,
you know,
we put the little thing down between his chin and his shoulders to keep his chin
down.
Uh,
I'd keep stuff to keep his hands up,
put weights in his hands,
put stuff under his arms,
hours and hours.
And he would drill it,
drill a,
drill it.
And then the second he hit someone and just saw that little spark in the eye,
that killer instinct would take over.
And he dropped his hands to his hips.
He put his chin up in the air and just starts swinging for the knockout.
You'd forget everything.
Well the crazy thing about chuck is for the longest time he could take
everything.
Yeah,
he could take all of it.
And he beat a lot of guys cause he took their best shots.
And then when they didn't expect him to be around,
he's knocking them out.
Like Allister,
we fought Alastair and pride.
That was God damn wars are won.
Round War Alster came out very strong.
Hit him with some really good knees,
real sharp,
but chuck could fucking take it and stay in there.
Yeah.
And he would.
And he,
he hit so hard and uh,
and then when he,
he,
his Chin wasn't quite what it was.
He just,
he didn't want to change a style.
Uh,
we didn't want to turn it into a more cerebral game.
He wanted to go out a banger.
Hey,
did,
isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
Well I guess,
you know,
it's so hard for the average person,
even me included.
I might've been there for all of it,
but it's so hard for me to even understand what it must've been like to be that
guy.
You know,
that he was,
when the UFC first exploded,
chuck was the poster boy.
I mean,
he was the guy and you couldn't get like a better guy as far as like his style
and like the result of his fights.
Like,
if you wanted people to watch a fight,
you watch a chuckle Delphi,
like the Bob Aloof fights are the Randy fights and God damn,
he fought exciting.
I mean he was one of the most all time destructive guys in the history of MMA
and he,
he was the guy that was at the top right when it exploded.
So it was so fascinating.
So fascinating to watch that guy's career.
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
it was quite a ride.
Oh,
he was in an animal.
He was a fucking animal.
And here's when he stopped and Alastair this then pride.
Yeah.
That overhand right.
Crazy overhand.
Right.
He throws,
he had hit him a few times before that too though.
He had tagged him.
He was starting to wear on them.
Yeah.
And then boom,
we just put them away.
That crazy right hand that he used to throw it.
That was the strangest punch.
He would throw it right in between their gloves.
Yeah.
And,
and it's a glove was going to be the same.
Glover's got that bad.
He's got some serious one punch knockout power too.
He,
yeah,
we were training yesterday and uh,
it's,
it's scary because I want to use these hands usually with hard punches.
It hurts your shoulder when you're hitting the holding the meds.
But with him it goes,
it doesn't even,
it doesn't even hit the shoulders because it feels like your hands,
every time he hits it actually feels like you're the bones.
There's 28 little bones in your hand.
I mean there's 28 little bones in there and it feels like they're all separating
every time he hits.
And it,
I mean,
it's not even pain.
It just has such a weird feeling.
And I just,
I just,
you know,
and then I get flashbacks every time he hits me cause it hits my hand.
But it goes all the way into my brain and I have flashbacks to when I was 14
years old getting hit in the head by Samoans back in a while.
It's like,
I was like,
yes,
deep flashbacks play.
You're holding pads.
I do.
And I'm like,
uh,
but then I realize where I am.
I'm just thinking,
I just feel sorry for anyone that he hits and makes contact with,
with that punch.
Cause it's the punch I've never felt before.
It's the power.
Chuck had a different power.
Chuck Chuck's power was mainly that straight.
Right.
And then he had the overhand,
uh,
but it was timing.
Chuck was about timing.
Had great timing.
Very accurate too.
I saw him when he fought,
uh,
Vernon Forrest force for none.
That Jerry Foran,
Vernon white Vernon.
Why?
He was like,
tiger was walking backwards and I was yelling.
I was yelling at him this,
I was yelling at him for the signal for the right hand.
And he actually looked over and,
and went like that.
And the announcer said something like,
I think it was a you that fight.
Um,
he's think it was me.
Then he was looking over to the corner and they just turn around.
I said,
okay.
And he threw the right and he just,
boom.
I think,
I think it may have been me.
I do,
I do.
I think it was,
it was like when I first started working for the UFC and I was yelling,
I was yelling the number for that punch.
And he like looked okay,
bang,
I did it.
Then he was out.
Yeah.
And he hit him right in the eyeball too.
That was a brutal pump.
He has.
Yeah.
He had,
uh,
he had really hard hands and he,
he punched really hard and he had perfect timing and clover clover without the
timing or with the timing.
I'm not saying he doesn't have the timing,
but he doesn't need the timing.
He'll just,
he has Tyson power.
Like Tyson a one punch,
go to sleep.
Wow.
It's scary.
Well,
I saw the Bader fight and you can see it in that fight,
you know,
and uh,
he,
uh,
he performed very well against rampage to,
yeah.
And then,
you know,
you see the Kyle Kingsbury fight,
that was just an unbelievable mauling.
I mean,
Kingsbury's a really tough guy,
a really good athlete and such a great guy,
but Glover just was so outmatched him.
It was,
it was a mauling.
We did not like that mint.
Chuck hated that fight.
In fact,
chuck,
because we love Kyle and he his mind,
could you not?
Yeah,
he's my fanny pack of Jammy pack partner.
We actually have a jam off because I have a,
I have a song on a dance on Youtube cause I did a little dance and uh,
with my jammy pack,
I love to dance.
And uh,
so I challenged,
uh,
Kyle,
but I mean you can't not love Kyle when Kyle,
um,
would come around camp for chuck towards the end.
It was just not even as a spider point anymore.
Just you want him his energy.
His is,
he's a martial artist and uh,
and it,
he emulates just,
uh,
Kyle Kingsbury Enos.
Yeah,
Kyle's a really good guy.
He just couldn't,
couldn't be nicer,
couldn't be smarter.
And now I'm really good athlete too.
It's coming to Matt and Matt may late in his life though,
you know?
Yeah.
And it would've been interesting if that kid got involved in him and maybe he
was like 14 or something like that,
you know?
Oh,
he started later.
Yeah,
I believe so.
I'm pretty sure he was an athlete first at Bressler.
Um,
I don't think he was a wrestler.
I think he's like a football player.
So,
yeah.
Super Athlete though.
Yeah.
I love love.
I don't know if he's retired.
I think he was thinking of retiring.
He had a bunch of tough fights and Glover fight was one of them.
It was a real tough fight.
It chuck was checking
it was yelling from the side choke cause he was on top of him and and chuck just
wanted to choke them out so they,
he would tap right.
Did not want any more damage.
Cause we love Kyle.
Right.
We hated taking that fight.
Yeah.
Does it,
was that,
is that dangerous when you have a situation like that and you know your guy is
going to face him,
is that,
is it dangerous?
Is in any way like to have that attitude to go into a Dick?
Glover doesn't have that attitude.
Right.
He does it.
I mean as much as he likes him,
he's there to do the job.
Jack was a glove,
was there,
did Java and clover didn't have the closeness that we did to him cause he came,
uh,
Kyle came around more when Glover was when on his hiatus to Brazil.
So he didn't have quite the closest.
He really liked him,
but I mean the,
the MMA spirit,
um,
and I'll take out an m the maa spirit,
martial arts,
um,
is just so different than boxing,
which is,
I mean technically a marsh art too,
but they just don't carry themselves.
Most of them,
like martial artists,
they carry themselves like more like thugs or just they don't have the same
comradery.
I mean,
I have a picture of a sailor of his fight in,
I'm in Kentucky,
I don't even know.
I forgot the guy's name.
Really tough strong wrestler.
Um,
he lost a close decision.
It was his last fight.
Um,
but they were actually the day before the fight at the Wayne.
they were,
they were hanging out,
playing video games together,
like huddle together.
And I was,
and I didn't know who that guy was at first.
And I walked over,
hey,
what's up man?
What's your name?
And he's like,
so and so I go,
aren't you guys fighting tomorrow?
And they go,
yeah,
coach,
we just gotta hold on.
We got to finish this game.
And they hung out for like two hours at the way in.
And then the day the fight,
they were like hanging out in the dressing room and then they went out and put
on a brutal,
I mean,
it was a very brutal fight.
It was a good fight and it was a brutal,
they didn't hold back anything.
They definitely fought.
Yeah.
It was Dennis Bermudez who's a great guy as well.
And I mean,
and that's the comradery.
You don't see that in boxing and MMA.
You see it more than you don't.
Yeah.
It's cool to see.
It's cool.
I love it.
You know,
it was cool to when,
uh,
when Anderson was champion and George St Pierre was champion,
all those champion Anderson was champion.
When,
when those guys would like get into the cage and bow,
and I'd go,
well,
look at this.
Here's the best guys in the world today.
And all of them behave like martial artists.
All of them have the martial arts,
the the ethics,
all of them bow and face their opponent and they all are very well versed.
They have lifelong Leono,
lifelong martial artists and those are the best guys.
It seems like as time goes on and as guys get better,
they start to realize that the correct way to live your life is the way the
ancient warriors did.
Like they weren't stupid.
Like they didn't come up with all these ethics because it was cute.
They did it because it makes you a better person and all these ideas of peace
and harmony until battle and the the,
the zen state of mind,
the ability to achieve this oneness with,
with,
with the task at hand.
There's a reason why they invented all that stuff and for like boxers and you
know like a lot of MMA guys that came from even a wrestling background,
they don't recognize the power of that.
The,
those philosophies like those philosophies remove a lot of the uncertainty and
the doubt that people have,
they removed.
You know who you are if you follow those philosophies.
Yeah,
I,
I think I see a lot of the boxes didn't have that.
And I came up in a box and background and I was on boxing teams.
I was on the all army boxing team,
I was on a lot of boxing teams and there was camaraderie with our team,
but there wasn't with other teams.
And I mean guys like chuck,
I think chuck was one of the first guys that started that.
Um,
the Gracies did too.
but even,
even a lot of the wrestlers,
they've replaced Sensei with coach and they,
and they use the word coach with the same reverence that,
that a lot of karate guys,
you sensei and,
and so they,
I think a lot of the wrestlers do have a more of of that work ethic,
martial arts ethic.
Um,
and like I said,
it comes through with the coach and stuff,
but you'll see that with chuck.
We'll see that with the w Liotta when he kicked,
um,
Ms. Dot.
Munoz in the head.
And he stood over him and he just like could've hit hidden one or two more
times.
And he,
he knew he was out and there's no need to.
But I've also seen Dan Henderson do that.
Um,
and I've seen him not do it,
but I've actually seen him do it when he wasn't angry at with a guy.
I remember he did that with one of the graces and they Renzo or Enzo or didn't
need you that when he
stop Henzel was completely out.
He could have hit him again.
And a lot of people do,
a lot of people will every single time.
But yeah,
a lot of the guys just like,
they,
they know that no need to and some guys know that there's no need to,
but they still do.
Yeah.
And sometimes it's the same guy.
It's just different fight.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But um,
but like,
uh,
check had that from the very beginning.
He also had that with Randy,
you know,
cause they were,
they weren't like friends where they call each other and hang out,
but they were,
they were friendly.
And Randy came out to train with me a couple of times and they,
him and chuck,
that was before they fought the first time,
but not too far before they finally got signed to fight and they hung out a
little.
So they were good.
They were,
they never weren't.
Okay.
Chuck was okay with almost all of his opponents.
He wasn't with two of them that I know of.
But I think every other one he was very friendly with before and after the
fight,
but never during,
yeah.
Never during.
But yeah,
he's,
he recognizes there's no need to be an asshole,
you know,
w you're going to fight no matter what.
I'll talk all you want,
all that.
Great.
But when,
when all the guys did talk,
like if anybody,
like,
like Tito,
like it was a perfect example,
and that's like one of the more bitter rivalries that he had.
You know,
it's like you could see it pisses him off.
Yeah.
It's not really a good strategy.
Wasn't a good strategy to put to chuck off now
and,
and Tito.
Yeah.
He said something about,
um,
you know,
it bothered chuck the most,
um,
was not what someone said to him because he almost everything could go off his
shoulder.
I mean,
you know,
like chuck,
who's Big Fan,
I think it's Shaq O'Neal or one of the basketball players.
I'm not sure who it was,
but he was actually in the dress room after chuck beat somebody and chuck came
in and this Shaq O'Neal or whatever is it.
That's an ideal Shaquille O'Neal.
And he said,
you're my favorite fighter.
And check talk to them.
I saw the way chuck,
you know,
interact with them or a famous movie star Chuck Interact with him.
He interacted with a guy on the street asking for a quarter the exact same way
he interacts with everyone with dignity and respect.
Um,
and he's a family man,
like no other.
But so when,
when Tito did say some things,
he didn't bother chuck that what it said to him if by their chuck,
because he thought his kids would hear that and he didn't want his kids hearing
that kind of stuff.
So he was pissed.
And you saw this 23 punches land on Tito's face in about a second and a half
flat.
That was one of his best performances.
Yeah.
And those,
those were epic fights and epic in,
in different ways like the Randy fights where epic,
those were,
those were defining cause I think the first one like losing that first one
really taught him something,
talking about
being prepared and being condition that he just,
he got out worked,
you know,
he got to a situation where he,
uh,
you know,
he underestimated and Randy's on top of him and he's exhausted and Randy pounded
on them.
Yeah,
he was.
And uh,
chuck was never the conditioning guy.
He trained really hard and gotten a condition,
but he didn't love to work out.
He loves to fight.
He was a fighter.
I mean there's some people that love to fight and want to be a fighter,
but they don't know.
They love to be a fighter.
They want to be a fighter.
Check,
love to fight.
He didn't care about being a fighter.
He just loved to fight.
He was in there 11 to five thing.
I contradict myself.
But he did.
He just loved to fight.
Um,
and,
and um,
he,
you know,
he just,
he just wanted to fight.
He didn't,
the conditioning part was so he could be,
you know,
be a better at fighting.
He didn't love to work out.
He loved to fight.
That was very few people do love the stove or loans yesterday.
Yeah.
Like Glover court McGee loves it.
Grilling Glover loves it.
Yeah.
Court Mcgee.
He runs a lot with weight vests on too.
Right?
He does crazy stuff.
And I hail call me like every other day.
All right,
coach,
what am I,
what am I doing?
10,
I'll put them on these crazy things and sometimes just,
you know,
not expect him to do the whole thing.
And they'll call me back that night.
He goes,
well,
my time was so-and-so and I did this much weight.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
Okay.
And he's,
yeah,
he's a freak.
I mean,
he's a freak of,
of conditioning nature and,
and sales.
Glover.
Yeah.
I uh,
clover,
I brought Glover to a crossfit cause I'm a crossfit,
a certified guy.
Um,
and I brought him in the early days across that I brought him to a seminar,
a certification,
and they picked him out of the audience because he was the buff guy.
And they want,
they always want to make them look bad.
So they were,
so basically they're trying to call them out to try to dog him and they're
trying to have them go against this girl doing overhead squats,
which is the really tough movement,
um,
for even a muscular guys cause it has so much to do with flexibility and balance
and,
and uh,
and shoulder pliability.
So they call him up and he did 21 of them in a row and everybody in the audience
was like,
okay,
he just made it feel to you guys.
And then say,
the crossfit guys said,
okay,
now go to a muscle up and Glover,
what's a muscle of,
I don't even know what that is.
So they showed them to the ranks and he did a muscle up.
He never even knew it and what it was.
No,
he did it.
So,
I mean that's clovers and natural,
uh,
free to just like a quarter's,
well,
all my guys have to go through my training regimen,
which most don't like,
but they actually love it.
They like,
Hey,
what did we do today,
coach?
So,
well,
you're,
you're famous for having some pretty outlandish shuck strength and conditioning
methods.
Like you like to use wheel barrels,
you like to use,
uh,
you'll,
you like to make guys do like heavy actual work.
I want to,
I want them to,
yeah,
I do.
I have to work hard and I want it to,
to that limit because in a fight you go to that limit so many times.
And I realized that and I had to get my strength and conditioning and stuff in
order by reading books because at 14 years old and Honolulu,
Hawaii,
and when I decided I wanted to fight in the golden gloves,
I didn't know how to get in shape.
So I went to the library,
I was in junior high school and I got a library library book and it was a rocky
Marciano and I read that.
So I learned that I should go run two miles every day.
That's what Marsianno did.
He ran and there was a bunch of other stuff but there was since he,
what do you think it was bad though cause I was trying to gain weight and rocky
Marciano was light for heavyweight so he,
he advocated eating a lot of Graham crackers and shakes and riff crackers and
crackers and shakes.
It was in his book,
his book is like Britain and probably 1952 but uh,
he,
cause he said that way we'll put on some extra muscle.
He was,
he was a heavyweight,
you know,
and he was walking around it like,
172 pounds
once the only that light,
I thought he was about one 90
no,
he would fight.
He would try to fight.
I think he would get in the high eighties but he would walk around lighter and
he would try to gain the way to weigh in because there's no way clause.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
I didn't know,
I thought he was a,
I thought it was very light,
but we're in people smaller back then,
except for guys like Primo Carnera and you know who fought,
did he fight Lewis?
Who?
The Primo Carnera fight.
He fought Dempsey,
didn't he get knocked out of the ring by Dempsey?
Yeah,
I think it was Dempsey.
it was before the famous picture.
Yeah,
that's right.
And he was a legitimate,
enormous giant guy.
Sevenish yeah,
he was seven feet.
Huge.
But like Joe Lewis also fairly light guy,
right.
He was in the 90s.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
It's so hard for people to imagine that the heavyweight champion of the world
was a buck 90.
Yeah.
And I mean,
and when you look at someone like,
um,
like mark Marsianno hits so hard,
you know,
or even Mike Tyson,
I mean,
I mean he,
he,
he bulked up and wait in what to 12 to 15 solid as a rock.
Yeah.
And he was so,
he was smaller than most of his opponents.
He was such a God damn nightmare though.
Doesn't Mike Tyson of the 1980s what a nightmare.
It must've been the fight that guy,
like just try to keep them off,
keep them off,
keep them off.
And he's just swinging at you.
Yeah.
And every pint in we even and every punch and he,
and he was such a,
he was such a student of the game.
Yeah.
Huge,
huge team in the game.
So he knew,
he knew exactly how to land those lows.
Solid punches.
And that's,
that happens to be clover's idle.
Yeah.
Not In life,
but as a,
as a,
as a fighter.
Well,
uh,
didn't gloss over,
have a fight and Tyson was in the audience and he
came up and hugged him afternoon.
Which fight was that?
That was a,
the one that was to Hoonah that's doing that.
It was a tough mother.
He's very tough.
Very tough.
So Glover is now
finally after all this time for a lot of folks who don't know,
there's very few guys to this day that aren't in the UFC that you look at and
you go,
damn,
I wish that guy was in the UFC.
Like pretty much all of them are in the UFC today.
There's a couple of guys in my opinion,
um,
uh,
I think Michael Chandler and Eddie Alvarez or two guys that I'd love to see in
the UFC,
I think they're super high level.
You know,
I think,
um,
I think there's some,
there's some talented guys that fight in other organizations,
but the big name was always Glover.
It was always the guy can't get a visa.
I can't get a visa.
And people would tell you,
wait till you see this motherfucker.
And I watched some of his fights online and then,
you know,
we finally got a chance to have them in the octagon and I was like,
wow.
Yeah,
this guy's legit.
He's very legit.
He's very well rounded.
Like what an epic,
well rounded game,
good kicks,
good punches,
good chin,
good aggression,
great Jujitsu,
good wrassling,
vicious ground and pound,
very solid,
you know,
not,
not really missing anything.
Conditioning is off the hook conditioning and the ability to take a shot and
then recover really quickly and hurt the other guy.
Like the Bader fight was a perfect example of that.
You know,
Bay Bader clipped him and he knocked,
paid her out cold just a few seconds later.
I mean,
it was just a beautiful left hand that he and landed on Bader.
Yeah.
He's a monster man.
Yes.
Well he fought,
showed Yuca
[inaudible] yeah,
I saw that fight that was in WC.
Right.
Devy see,
and that was,
uh,
that was a fight that,
um,
Dan Henderson called me and asked me to take because Dan was,
uh,
managing,
so Gq.
Yeah.
Here's,
so could you,
here's him just teeing off on,
yeah.
He crushed that dude.
And so could you was like,
after that went on that Hoe that horrifying tear in pride,
right?
Well,
he was destroying people.
It started with a Roman destroyed or run it.
And we started with [inaudible].
He fought little Nog,
knocked out little Nog with a wrist.
Remember that he like,
went to throw like a left hand and like caught him with the wrist and starched
him.
I mean,
he had unbelievable power.
He knocked him out,
knocked a rona out,
and one of the most terrifying Kaos ever.
And you thought,
Holy Shit,
who's going to beat this guy?
Like,
and then you realize,
well he was Homans already beat him.
Glover beat them.
And then you wash the Glover fight and you're like,
Whoa,
what the fuck man Glover is an animal.
Yeah.
In any of that really fast knock out a six second knock out of uh,
is another WDC fight the guy out of a vandelays camp.
I Dunno,
it was,
yeah,
George,
it was George something.
Not Jorge,
but George,
well Glover's now going to fight for the title and it's really interesting
because it's a no,
it was long time coming just to get him into the,
the UFC had visa problems for a solid six mirrors nightmare and now he's
fighting John Jones and uh,
Gino John is coming off really tough fight with Gustafson.
I think Jon Jones is going to be highly,
highly motivated.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
he realizes how close that fight was and how dangerous that fight was.
That was,
that was a wake up call kind of a fight where it's like,
look man,
you know,
this is out there,
that Gustafson guys are out there and just go over to share guys out there too.
So I think John is going to come in like super motivated and he's such a
talented kid too.
I mean Jon Jones,
think about that guy,
youngest guy to ever win MMA title at at the highest level,
fights shogun for the title and stops him.
I mean he beats him up,
beat him up,
murders a mall,
awesome.
Hit Him with a flying knee seconds into the fight.
Just so creative.
So like ticks a lot of chances and risk does a lot of shit that you don't expect
and and still doesn't even as a champion,
you know,
I mean,
he's not,
he's not changing his game at all as a champion.
No,
he's a,
he's a bad motherfucker.
That is a fantastic fight.
Yes it is.
A lot of tools.
But yeah,
that one,
that one punch.
I just,
I keep thinking of my hands separating and the bones in them and just how hard
he hits.
I'm like,
it's going to be a good fight and it's a,
it's a great matchup.
But it's,
I mean,
I don't think,
I mean I,
you know,
I would get real nervous to fight Jones real nervous to fight someone like even
jail who's like his takedowns are so crazy,
be so nervous to fight,
you know,
rampage cause it was aggression.
There's,
there's so many guys with so many tools,
Anderson,
but that,
just knowing the power that that clover has,
I think that would put the most fear into me.
Wow.
Just,
he's just hitting that hard.
It just be like,
what do I do?
I can do this,
this and this and this and get away from it.
And I could try to do this on him.
But the second that handled lands,
it's going to,
I don't know what to do.
What's not going to break.
Do you have any videos of him like hitting the bag or hitting the pads that are
online?
Uh,
not really.
We did one yesterday and Instagram one.
People love watching training videos.
Yeah.
People love watching those.
I love watching those.
Like I love those countdown to the UFC shows because I get here you go right
here.
You get to see in those countdown to the UFC shows.
He get to see guys in their honing things up,
tightening their skills and it just makes the anticipation,
the fight ever more exciting.
You know like this upcoming card this weekend,
the Fox card Henderson versus a Josh.
Yeah,
that's Josh Thompson.
Yeah.
Fucking love that fight.
That is a great fight.
Ben Henderson and Josh Thompson.
Yeah.
That is going to be an exciting car that's in Chicago,
Huh?
Yeah.
Loved that fight.
I love both of them.
Those guys are dead.
I love that Josh Thompson is finally getting his due.
Yeah.
He's been of the top guys at
155 pounds for a long time and it took that Nate Diaz fight for people to see,
you know,
of a focused,
motivated Josh Thompson is undoubtedly world class.
I mean the first guy to stop Nate Diaz like that in the octagon.
I mean,
who do you remember?
Anybody ever doing that to Diaz?
It's tough as shit date.
Nate Diaz takes a hell of a punch.
Hell of a punch.
He's durable as fuck.
Josh Thomson stopping him was a huge victory that you really got to see what
Josh has fully capable of coming into his own.
You know,
he's got it all.
He's a great wrestler
in this fight with Gilbert Melendez.
Woo.
That last fight with Melendez and strike force.
What a fight that was.
God Damn,
that was a fun fight.
That was a really,
really close fight to a lot of people had to Thompson winning that fight.
You know,
it was very closed.
Very controversial.
And what a great fight it was.
Gilbert Melendez.
A fucking savage.
Yeah,
he's,
he's uh,
he's like an old school Mexican boxer.
I love that dude.
Love watching that dude fight.
Yeah,
he'll go.
Yeah.
Like he chose to get into a fight like that with Diego.
Like he could have avoided that.
He could have fought like a,
you know,
more tactical.
Could he used his wrestling more?
Could have,
nope.
Just met them in the center.
And they both threw down.
Whew.
They fought if I'd a Henderson the same way.
Yup.
Yeah.
That was a very,
very close fight as well.
Very close,
very close fight.
I love that these guys are so evenly matched because one or two or more are
going to have to rise to the occasion.
They're going to have to see what's going on in this division and you to fucking
insane division where you got Anthony Pettis who's just Uber talented kid.
Ridiculous kicker.
I mean by probably one of the best kickers in MMA today,
one of the best strikers,
like tactical strikers.
He's so slick.
And then you take him to the ground and he's got laser sharp Jujitsu.
I mean that arm bar was fucking magical.
It was so perfect the way.
Set that up and slapped it on.
It was a vice,
I mean that was going nowhere.
The fight was over.
That was like real high level shit.
So you got him and then you got Benson.
He's fantastic and guarantee you he's going to be motivated as hell coming off
of the loss and coming off of,
you know,
he just didn't think he was going to get caught in that position.
He was on top.
He thought he was okay.
Kent getting caught like that.
Losing twice.
I wrote to him,
he's kickboxer.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
you can't call this a kickboxer.
He's too good.
Then you don't think he's a kickbox and you get kid kicked out of the liver.
Yeah,
well I remember watching him on the ground before he was knocking him.
He's still always kicking really well and always doing really well,
but there was a couple of fights where he got taken to the ground where I was
even more impressed with the way cinched up a cha,
a triangle on somebody.
I forget the fight,
but I was like,
Whoa,
this kid is legit.
Not just stand up,
but he's dangerous as fuck from his back,
which is rare among fighters.
Fairly rare.
He's like,
he's,
he's definitely
coming off of a or comes from a very,
very talented and creative camp.
Duke Roufus is a,
what,
a gem of a human being too.
You know,
couldn't get a nicer guy to like run your camp and he runs.
Yeah.
He runs it and he runs it well.
He,
I think he's,
he's probably one of my favorites.
Mine as well.
He's a great coach.
He's a just a great guy too.
I love sitting there and talking to him and picking his brain and I've had long
conversations with him picking his brain about striking techniques and about
what guys are doing differently and what,
you know,
what,
what you have to do to avoid this and why this guy is standing like this and
he's setting up that and then,
you know,
he's got such a wealth of knowledge.
Yeah.
He's,
I'm more like,
just go
if you get,
no,
it was,
man,
you give great corner advice,
I'll tell you that.
Yeah.
Fuck No.
You know what's good about your corner advice?
You're,
you don't freak out.
You don't,
you don't lose your calm.
You're always common.
The guy down while you're in there.
I'll never forget.
Um,
uh,
when court fought the,
that first big fight,
was it Ryan?
Um,
God dammit Jansen.
Yes.
Ryan Jensen.
That was the fight and Ryan Jensen came out like a house on fire in the first
round.
So huge to Tammy looked good in that,
in that first fight.
I mean it was one of the best performances of Ryan's career.
That first round,
the first round of that fight is scary.
And then you got him down,
you got court in between rounds and you said,
I'll never forget this because you're so calm.
He said,
don't worry,
your conditioning is going to take over.
You're going to take over from here.
And that dude came out like a God damn John Hackleman robot and just did exactly
that.
Just put it on him,
chased him down and eventually finished them.
And I was like,
wow,
that is a unbelievable turnaround of events because yeah,
it was,
cause Kyle,
it looks so good in that fight.
Or Ryan Rather,
Ryan Jensen looks so good in that fight,
in that first round.
I mean he showed like his real potential that he's a really talented kid,
that you know,
there's a lot of those guys that are like that,
these really talented kids that may or may not ever fight for the title,
but they had moments inside that cage where you're like,
Whoa,
this guy's got potential.
And I think that first round was one of them.
But yeah,
the way you were so calm and so like collected in the corner.
You like you had a physically calming effect,
you know,
and all your experience and you're talking to him.
It's pretty valuable shit to have in your corner,
man.
Yeah,
I was,
I was pretty nervous going down.
I think the,
the,
another close one in the corner was clay harvest sin against Justin Edwards.
Put Key,
get closer to that thing or pull it closer to you if you could.
Yeah,
I think another club,
there we go.
A closer one was a clay harvest and when he fought Justin Edwards.
Yeah,
another,
it was so close.
Then sometimes you can tell that the guy just needs this or that said or either
whether it be instruction,
direction or motivation.
I mean,
you never tell a guy you're losing,
right.
I'll never tell the guys listen,
because all he's going to hear,
like when you,
you know,
when you're a parent,
you tell,
you tell the kid you're acting stupid.
All he hears is your stupid.
Even though I have said that before as a parent,
um,
but when you say you know,
you're losing,
they're just going to,
you know,
you're going to lose or anything with the word losing in it.
It's just,
it's a negative and they're just going to hear,
oh shit,
I lost.
And they,
it takes a little bit,
I think out of them.
What do you do though?
When a guy's lost four rounds in a row and you've got to give them some kind of
instruction,
you just go straight technical.
Do you tell him he has to win this?
You have to stop this fight.
You have to sell instead of saying when you lost the four rounds,
you just say you have to win this one.
Right.
You know,
you have to win this next round.
You have to knock him out or you going to lose and then you gonna lose your
house and your kids and your wife will probably divorce you and somebody will
fucking take your lunch money when you get home.
That's a lot of pressure.
I think you put an extra pressure on them.
I don't know.
Yeah.
So is that okay?
So I want to see human.
Sometimes I get emotional.
Does it vary?
Does your approach vary depending on like the guy different for chuck,
the Navy for Siler?
Yeah.
Very different.
And you just have to feel the guy and then feel the fight.
Cause I've been doing corners since [inaudible] 74 1974.
That's insane.
Yeah.
Tell me,
I,
so I,
I mean I get like,
I'm real emotional too,
especially with my fighters.
Um,
and I get,
some of it is,
I'll have my own little breakdowns,
but I don't want them to see it cause I get very emotional.
I've had like Chuck Glover,
I vet all my guys at one time or another.
Go coach.
It's okay man.
Just relaxed because I get really,
sometimes I get worked up too cause I get really nervous cause I don't like to
see my guys see.
I'd rather have all my guys in my gym training,
having a great time doing Hawaiian Kempo doing pit stuff,
hitting the bag,
spying once in a while,
but nobody fighting.
That would be,
that'd be my dream come true.
My passion is training people and having fun training with them and just having
a martial arts school,
putting our geese on and going to the beach on Saturdays with our gies and
running and everybody looks at us and we're just like,
Hey,
what's up?
But uh,
but the chuck stopped all that cause that's what we're,
that's the path I was on.
You know,
I retired from fighting and I didn't want to fight anymore.
I hate fighting.
I hate fighting when I was fighting,
you know.
But that's all I knew how to do.
And that's what,
it's a long story.
Growing up in Hawaii,
it wasn't a pretty picture.
Um,
uh,
but then chuck come came to me one day and just said,
Hey John,
you there?
You can try fighting.
I was like,
what do you mean?
He was like in the ring.
I go,
whoa,
you serious bro.
I've already fought enough for all of us.
Let's just,
let's just have fun training.
He goes,
I just want to try it.
If it doesn't work out,
it doesn't work out.
I go,
all right.
Just a couple of fights and to see where it goes.
And it was chocolate l so,
so after,
by plans of just having a fun little martial arts school called the pit and a
bunch of fun guys training and having a great time and wearing a Gucci all over
the place and fanny packs and shit.
And it went to hell.
Well,
fucking hell.
I never came back.
One of the greatest careers in,
in training ever.
And it went to hell.
It went down.
And then because chuck,
towards the end of his career,
you know,
we decided,
okay,
we decided when he was going to retire.
And,
um,
there was a little controversy on that,
uh,
with the Dana white thing.
Um,
but we,
I mean all of us,
including Dana,
who,
you know,
we went ahead a couple of interactions but he loves chuck like I do.
And he always wanted the best for chuck.
Like I did and it was like,
but we're coming from different angles.
How as a trainer,
and he was a promoter,
you know,
uh,
and we,
but we both love chuck and wanted the best for chuck.
But then towards the end of his career I go,
Oh shit,
okay you take over the team and I'm just going to go work,
you know,
work with working in my school and do my what I love to do the pit and you can
train the fighters and I'll help you out.
But I don't want to travel anymore.
I don't want to work anymore corner cause all right man.
No problem.
Yeah,
yeah.
We see how that worked out.
Now he's like fucking Kardashians in Calabasas and he doesn't even have the
time.
He doesn't even have the time basically for anything but to be chuckling.
L and that's all he,
that's his,
that's his life now.
While he's a legend,
he's a legend and a superstar and ease and there's nobody that,
that deserves it more.
And he's a great representative of the sport because he's like Super Nice Guy.
He's a,
he's a great person,
a rep,
uh,
representative of being a man.
He's starting a family.
He's the most loyal,
he's a low,
most loyal human alive.
He's a scary stuff.
He's a very noble guy and people don't even know the stories about him.
And he's just,
he is that guy through and through.
And I mean,
I'm probably the closest to him and I just,
I know you know everything it is.
If it wasn't for one guy,
you wouldn't be known as a trainer.
I think I,
yeah,
probably could.
Oh,
I wouldn't be training.
I think if it wasn't for him,
they'd still be,
you know,
some of the other guys that were around.
But I'd be,
you'd be a martial arts and striving.
That's about,
I'd be,
and I'd be so happy.
I said,
what is it about the competition?
What is it about fighting that is distasteful or you don't like or nerve
racking?
What is it?
I mean,
I,
you know,
people you love competing.
It makes me cry and I don't,
I don't like to cry and I definitely don't like my guys to see me cry.
How does it make you cry?
It makes me sad just to see them get hit really.
And just realizing what I went through when I was fighting and,
and not liking and not wanting to do it.
And then just wanting to be at a different place and getting so nervous and then
the late let down of the fight.
We know whether they win or lose.
I mean,
I did mean let down,
like if they lose,
but just it's over now and you're just like,
okay.
But then I know I have to do it again.
But I love these guys.
I mean,
I love,
I love all of them.
I mean,
now that I've been involved in the sport,
I've become like,
you know,
I just like all these guys,
not even my own guys.
There's so many guys out there.
I,
I hate to see,
you know,
I get to see,
I hate to see any of the guys lose.
And even worse than that,
I hate to see them get hurt cause I know it hurts him.
No.
So I just,
I just don't like that.
So yeah,
if it wasn't for Chuck,
I'd be teaching karate happy as a pig in shit somewhere.
Just kind of to almost done.
Let's go
take on chuck,
was he,
he's going to retire when he wants to retire,
when he chooses to retire.
He's a man.
He's one of the great champions of all time.
When he chooses to retire,
that's when he retires.
And Dana was like,
look,
that's it.
You're retired.
And so that's where you guys had your issues.
Yours was almost sort of out of maybe like so much respect for the man and as a
competitor that you'll likely,
it's up to him.
He's got to make the decision,
you know,
you can listen to my advice,
but it doesn't matter.
You've got to make the decision where it's,
Dana was like,
he loves them.
I mean,
no doubt about it.
Dana fucking loves chocolate and he was looking at first best then.
And I say for a promoter,
I mean it's contrary.
It's contour counter to his own financial interests.
Chuck was a huge paper view.
Draw still would be if he came back today,
we got,
imagine God dammit if chocolate Gal came back today and him and Randy went out
at again,
chocolate Randy for Jesus Louisa.
So that would be a big pay per view.
Wouldn't happen.
It wouldn't happen.
It would never happen.
I would,
I don't care if I baseball bat break his legs and be like Nancy Kerrigan.
But if it did whatever,
what I'm saying is it would be a huge,
huge event,
but the UFC would never do it.
You know,
they would never get,
well,
first of all,
yeah,
they would never do it.
Oh,
he wanted,
but what people don't realize,
including Dana,
was I wanted to check to retire from before he even started.
I didn't want him to fight it all.
So it's was like,
but now he's fighting and he loves fighting.
It's his passion.
I mean,
he's going to say was say,
quit.
If I saw him get hurt really bad
like I did with retrain Clin,
right then it was done.
And,
and,
and right then I said,
that's it.
That's the last one,
no more.
Um,
and he didn't disagree and,
but,
you know,
emotions run high after the fight.
So we,
we decided right that that night we said,
well,
let's meet and such and such weeks we're going to go hike Madonna,
which is our mountain up there.
And we'll talk about it and we'll decide then.
And we walked up and Madonna and we said,
you know what,
no more.
That's it.
And we decided then and he came back down and then announced it.
That's awesome.
That was awesome.
Yeah.
That,
um,
what about the,
uh,
some of the other tough fights that he had had like the Rashad fire,
the shogun.
But I mean,
to be honest,
I've only seen chuck,
um,
knocked out that one time.
Rashad?
Yes.
Like the other cold.
Yeah.
The other times were like,
in boxing,
they would have been a flash knockdown.
He would have,
he would have taken an eight count.
Um,
what about the rich Franklin fight though?
But one is the one,
yeah,
I saw those two are the ones who really went out well,
to be honest,
the rich Franklin one,
um,
I didn't really notice the knock out as much as I did the cut.
The cut just freaked me the shit out.
You had a big cuddle.
Is Open upper lip.
It was,
it was,
it,
it freaked me out.
I mean,
I,
and I'm,
I've seen,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm an er nurse.
I mean in la I've seen,
you know,
hearts open,
but this one is just,
it,
just to see someone I love so much like that,
it just freaked me out.
Right.
So I was like that never,
you will never fight again.
I don't give a shit.
You're never going to fight again.
Just that cut,
you know,
it just freaked me the hell out.
And he had such good plastic surgery and it looks great now.
And someone,
yeah,
so,
and he agrees that perfect.
They did amazing job.
They did a great job and thanks to,
uh,
we got,
um,
we've got a doc,
a out of our town doctor Rushdie,
who's a great er doc,
and he traveled to that fight,
um,
and he actually went into the Er and said,
hey,
I know we're going to do it this way.
And they were gonna just have a regular er guy do it.
And he said,
no,
this is the lip.
This is,
this needs plastic work we're going to do.
So he went in and did his doctor thing and made sure it was done the right way
the first time.
Dr V was,
uh,
I mean chuck has some really loyal friends because of his loyalty to people.
And,
uh,
so that was,
that was lucky.
So after the Rashad fight,
um,
what was,
what was the thinking?
The thinking was just regroup.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he got knocked out.
I mean,
that was,
that was the first time I've ever seen him be knocked out.
I mean,
I've seen him knocked down,
but that was hard.
But you know,
I mean,
how many guys have you seen that came back and,
yeah,
I mean it says a lot.
Um,
and yeah,
decided to regroup and see,
you know,
what,
how he's feeling,
you sure you want to fight and let,
okay,
let's go.
Um,
but I was always pushing that,
but for him to retire,
but to just as a coach to keep putting that in his ear,
it's like,
well that's kind of like,
Oh yeah,
I'm a great trainer.
I'm telling you to retire.
And I'm saying hit harder.
It's like kinda going beltway.
So I kinda just let him as a grown man a decide and then,
and,
and like I said,
Dana's input was very,
you know,
it was important and it was as well taken.
It was just,
I didn't,
I didn't want that always throw shoved in Chuck's face because I was more trying
to build them up
more.
I think those,
um,
watching a guy from the beginning to the end and watching the end,
like a guy like chuck,
it's very important for young fighters too,
to see that there's a window in this thing.
Yeah.
And you really,
you don't have forever.
You have a few years and they'll all,
depending entirely upon how much damage you take,
how many injuries you get along the way,
and genetics and nutrition and health and taking care of yourself along the way
as well.
I've known water,
got to be able to see that there's,
there's different
TRT,
there's a beginning.
TRT is another one.
There's a beginning and then there's an end and when it's at,
it's over,
it's over.
Muhammad Ali's not gonna come back and win the title.
You know,
he's not going to get in the ring with Vladimir Klitschko and all of a sudden he
starts dancing and everybody starts cheering.
It's over.
Okay.
And that's not an extreme.
People think it's an extreme.
But Muhammad Ali,
I guarantee you can still remember the days when he was a boxer,
when he was the fucking baddest motherfucker on earth when he was lighting up
Cleveland Williams,
you know,
just hitting them with unbelievable combinations.
Fleet of foot.
He,
I'm sure that's still on his head.
Yeah.
It's hard for Todd,
for all of them.
Yeah.
It was hard for me to retire.
And I was never,
you know,
anywhere in that,
I never tasted the,
the fruits of,
of superstardom as a fighter.
I never got,
you know,
my ears blown out by the raging crazy crowds,
like chucked it when he walked into the cage and then to,
to,
to retire from that,
you know,
we can never understand it.
Know it was hard.
It was,
I mean,
cause I could like,
you know,
I'd walk in with him and I,
ve,
yeah.
Wow.
There they really like me.
So you brought up TRT and I think this is a huge subject,
uh,
in MMA right now.
And um,
I had a doctor on who's a specialist in traumatic brain injuries.
His name is Dr. Mark Gordon and he's a friend of mine and uh,
he treats people all the time,
soldiers,
football players,
people with traumatic brain injuries that are trying to recover.
And one of the symptoms is a lack of testosterone.
It's one of the major symptoms of traumatic brain injuries and one of the major
causes of depression,
the lack of energy as if they're their brain.
In just getting rattled.
It does a lot of damage to the pituitary gland.
And what he says is the pituitary gland is very sensitive to impacts,
whether it's car accidents or falling down or just banging your head on things.
Even soccer players just heading the soccer ball over long periods of time,
convert really fuck you up.
And,
um,
you know,
when,
when you realize that,
okay,
well you're,
you're dealing with professional fighters,
professional fighters that are on testosterone replacement.
Well,
why are they on testosterone replacement?
What's going on?
Are they on testosterone replacement because they have a legitimate medical
condition?
Or is it because they're,
they're just slowly starting to age and they would like a little pep in their
step?
Or is it because they've been hit in the head so many times their body's not
producing testosterone as much as it should?
And if that's the case,
that's a,
that's a very tricky subject,
isn't it?
Yeah,
I mean,
I have,
I'm not a doctor.
I'm a karate guy.
Um,
but I have my opinion on testosterone is like unless you have like Kleinfelter
Syndrome,
uh,
or some other low t um,
um,
sickness or disease or I think your t's going to be normal.
I think.
I think your testosterone was normal unless you've taken in the past.
And I think I would be willing to bet.
I'd be willing to bet that.
Okay,
so a repetitive,
you know,
chronic brain trauma.
Okay.
I think,
you know,
the endocrine and the pituitary are working together with the testes,
which is producing the testosterone.
I think I'm rattling the brain can cause a low t but I think it can also cause a
high tea because when you're messing with it,
you know,
some guys get extra high teas,
like a,
you know,
an HTA too.
I mean it does,
it throws it off.
So you think getting hit in the head could actually increase your production?
I think,
I think it can.
I think it can alter it.
That's interesting.
I think in alternate.
So it's just a theory.
I think it's,
yeah,
it's a theory because I think everybody's just a theory because I think they can
show,
um,
but I,
I would be willing to bet that I'd say,
I dunno a number,
I'll throw a number,
95% of guys that are doing TRT or they have a low t testing for low t and
they're in their 20s or 30s.
They've done some type of steroid in the past.
I'd be willing to bet that that's a pretty safe bet.
And so I think that is why their t his is low,
much more than them getting hit.
And if they have been getting hit that much,
I think other symptoms would manifest themselves before a low t such as slurring
in the speech.
Um,
memory,
cognitive,
uh,
you know,
alterations and stuff like that.
I think a dementia pugilistic,
uh,
which is getting hit too much.
That's what they call the chronic brain injury.
Um,
I think it would manifest itself in a lot of different ways before their t
started lowering.
And I think you say,
you know,
inbox and you'll see a lot more because they get hit.
I mean they get hit thousands of times more.
Then they do an MMA because of the wrestling,
the clinching,
the you said the,
the Jujitsu,
etc. But I,
I think people are in t because they've taken in the past,
so now it's low.
So they go to a doctor and a doctor says,
oh yeah,
you have low t here's a prescription for tea,
and now they're,
they're on t.
It certainly is possible.
That certainly is a possible scenario,
but one of the things that this doctor,
Dr. Mark Gordon has figured out is that it could be just one,
excuse me,
one head injury.
Okay,
one time falling down.
It doesn't slur your words,
right?
Don't just one,
one o one acute acute injury one one.
It doesn't even really have to be that brutal.
That's what's scary about it.
That one can throw it off.
It might not throw it off,
but just much like how chocolate Dell could take a terrific punch,
right?
Some guys can't take a punch at all,
It's just the way it is.
It's the way it's always going to be.
No one that we're not all built uniformly durable.
And for some people it just nothing.
One traumatic incident,
whether it's a,
you know,
getting hit in the head by a golf ball and they're never the same again
and you think it's never the same again.
There t level are never the same again possible.
Very possible that,
that they're,
they're connected,
that that head injury can disrupt the production of testosterone growth hormone.
The pituitary gland is,
you know,
very sensitive apparently according to him.
And he said,
a lot of guys get through it.
No problem.
They have long careers as football players and they're okay.
They have,
I mean there's more than one who've gone through football and not suffered brain
damage.
It does not.
It's not 100% everybody gets brain damage.
Right.
But he said one real good concussion,
one real good head injury,
the whole thing could get thrown off.
So I don't know.
I,
I wouldn't want to just give people the false courage that like,
or the false idea that if you don't slur your words,
you don't have brain damage.
Or if you don't slow your words,
you didn't have an injury,
right?
No,
no.
I'm not saying you do or don't,
but I'm just saying I think those symptoms would manifest themselves before an
actual clinical or diagnostic test where your tea is all of a sudden low.
And I'd like to see how that test was.
If they know it was one punch that knocked them out,
then all of a sudden was this t low before,
after.
I mean it would have to be a pretty weird,
pretty precise Dell,
you know,
double blind study that had been done for awhile and maybe it,
maybe it is right.
I mean I,
I'm,
I'm guesstimating but I,
I just being around the sport long,
long enough and knowing that I've seen guys just get pounded and pounded and
pounded and they just seem pretty t t a keyed up still.
Yeah.
And they're fine.
I've never taken tea so,
but I have heard a lot of guys throughout their career start slurring their
speech,
their,
their memory.
I've seen other things,
but I mean it's definitely an interesting study.
So if their t's low because of that one punch,
then okay,
so then you give them tea.
But if it's,
if there's other things also manifesting themselves in there,
they're actually getting early signs of dementia pugilistic uh,
then they probably shouldn't be fighting anyway.
Yeah.
That's the big question is that if you've incurred a head injury and the head
injury,
even if it was only one,
is somehow another altering your brain's ability to produce hormones.
Maybe you shouldn't be getting more head injuries.
So maybe you shouldn't be in a sport where the number one thing that people want
to do is give you a head injury.
Like that seems to be counterproductive.
That doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
So what does,
we're subject because so many guys are on testosterone replacement therapy now.
I mean,
it's a super,
super common situation.
This too common.
It's common.
Yeah.
It's way too common.
I mean,
and like your doctor,
Doctor Greg.
I will,
I'd love to read that by the way before we go.
Can you give me that because uh,
yeah,
I'll get you a connected cause I love stuff online.
I'm very interested in,
you know,
in the different,
uh,
you know,
stuff that happens to fighters medically.
But,
uh,
but I'd be willing to bet that the guys are on it because they want to recover
quicker from training.
I think they wanted better,
quicker results.
And I think what they don't realize is you got a 20 some year old,
30 year old guy and now he's doing TRT because,
um,
he got some,
I'm to say quack doctor,
but he got some guy to say,
okay,
you're,
you're low,
as easy as say low because you go,
I mean,
you do cycle your hormones and,
and,
and you know,
um,
so you could be on the low end of,
of,
of high end of normal.
So they give you your testosterone now,
now you're at 22nd,
you're a 27 year old guy,
you're taking your TRT and,
and um,
so it goes up to normal.
It goes a little higher.
Usually when you're training,
then they cycle it down before the test,
you know,
so they,
they're normal at the test.
But now with that abuse of the TRT or your testosterone,
now your,
your career's over your 32,
but now you need to take tier t for the rest of your life.
Yeah.
You shut your production down.
So,
so now you're 45 years old and you find yourself in between
John,
how about 25?
We've had guys in the UFC that were 25 years old that had testosterone use
exemptions.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I mean,
that seems crazy.
So,
okay,
so this year,
25 and you're not fighting anymore and you,
you don't have insurance and you don't have the money to pay for that,
that weekly testosterone shot.
I'm not a doctor,
but I would think that if it does shut it down or a fever,
if it even inhibits it like Lupron does,
then are you gonna are you going to start growing breasts and a vagina?
I don't know for sure.
What's Lupron?
Lupron is,
um,
Lupron is what we give 'em.
Um,
sexual offense.
It's chemical castration.
So that's what we'd,
I would give the,
um,
like the sex offenders in the,
when I worked at the prison or the State Hospital,
um,
I would give them their monthly Lupron.
So we keep their tea,
it's a testosterone and inhibitor,
so they can't,
so they don't,
they think that testosterone is what's making them rapists,
which I don't,
I don't think it is,
but whatever.
So we give it to them.
And then if you gave him a little extra by mistake once in a while,
then they,
you know,
they start growing,
they started growing breasts.
I don't think they actually grew a vagina.
That was kind of a joke.
But they do,
they do soften up and their facial hair goes away and,
and they,
they become curvy,
like a woman and become more of a family,
a lowering to the other inmates.
Really?
Yes.
So they would,
you would not saying you would,
someone might,
might do that on purpose to make them more sexually attractive to the inmates to
create a fattened cow as it were in my eye.
That would work that way.
It's sort of like that right up a cow for the slaughter.
Wow.
Brown was fun
as far as a nurse.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a testosterone neighbor,
so it turns the man into,
you know,
know a woman.
So it'd be like,
um,
but,
but um,
so you would,
I would think you're being on tests,
TRT as a fighter,
a young fighter.
Um,
um,
then all of a sudden you're not taking it.
If you don't have insurance and you can't afford the t testosterone,
you're screwed.
Yeah.
You're in a bad shape.
It took a while for your body to and start producing
its own testosterone to try it.
I had to fight or not too long ago,
uh,
an older fighter and he's,
he's on testosterone and he thought I,
he's,
he couldn't believe I wasn't on it.
I like,
I started taking anything in my life.
I mean,
the closest thing I've ever taken,
closest thing I've come to kiss testosterone is top ramen.
You know,
top ramen does not give you top drone.
I don't know.
TRT,
top ramen problem therapy.
That's what I used to take back home.
No,
no,
this doesn't work dude.
No wonder it you so hard.
You need to get your money back.
I was cause I was on TRD and that they,
that's what they got.
I thought it always meant,
oh you were just eating top ramen.
Ramen is,
it's one of the things I miss about being gluten free.
Ramen noodles,
chicken flavor.
I would do two of them.
Two of those packages together.
You know,
sometimes a crack an egg.
I've put like six eggs and just let it boil in him.
Ooh,
that's nice.
Yeah.
So I wish I could eat that can eat anymore gluten free.
My face gets in and look up.
Much more sexy.
Yeah,
you are sexy.
But I'm not saying I like,
I'm not saying all this,
speaking of like Amen.
Um,
and I'm not going to talk about me like a man cause that's something that
happened a while ago,
but my fighter,
you know I have the world's only bisexual,
bipolar and bilingual fighter.
Who's that?
Who Do you think Antonio Banuelos.
Oh,
I didn't know Ben Wallace was.
All of those things is really,
it's openly,
I didn't know this.
You're going to his Facebook and he has like pictures of him and address and
stuff.
He's one tough mother.
Oh fuck yeah.
Is very tough fighter.
Oh my God.
Been around for a while.
He was the guy when,
when Floyd Mayweather was talking shit.
Yeah.
Chuck Odell was like,
look,
I've got a guy who weighs 135 pounds million,
drop you and your fucking they a million.
He bet him a million and he would win that money.
Oh,
you can't Floyd Mayweather.
It's a fucking phenomenal boxer.
Yeah,
but the difference between a phenomenal boxer and the guy who has the ability to
stop a guy like Ben Wells from taking them down,
good fucking luck.
You know,
I learned that the hard way.
Good luck guy like that could take a guy who's not a boxer,
70 pounds heavier down.
You know a guy who doesn't know what he's doing.
You know,
if you're,
if you're like light and quick,
you think you're going to move out of the way and you're not going to,
he's going to shoot on one.
You're going to defend that.
He gets the other clamp,
his hands together and going for a fucking ride up in the air.
Boom,
down on your head.
He's dropping Hammerfest on you.
It's not a boxing match.
No,
no.
I know and are correct.
Like our karate guys in my neighborhood.
I mean,
I mean in my own neighborhood,
I don't go to a pit.
That guy wastes his time.
He teaches people take down defense and take downs and groundwork.
He goes,
we don't waste our time with that.
We,
we hit them while they're coming in and we knock them out.
They'll never get us to the ground and it's like actually good idea.
Did you ever try that?
It's a good strategy with a crane strike.
I tried it with a crane cranes.
It didn't work.
You ever seen monkeypod practice monkey on each other?
Shrunk Monkey.
A monkey would just bring just rescue.
How would you take a guy?
Dive is monkey.
What about a dragon?
What does the drag dragging clauses that tiger claw type on dragon breathing the
fire fire break or a snake or something.
They cannot take a guy down if he knows that.
And all the martial arts that were sort of exposed or integrated into mixed
martial arts,
the one that got really left out of the fucking dance was Kung Fu.
Boy It Kung Fu get fucking left out.
The music stopped at Kung Fu is standing in the musical chairs game of life.
Kung Fu was the standing motherfucker at the end of the martial arts parade.
I mean,
judo came in and a lot of people probably would've thought judo,
not the most effective con wrong.
She'll know con karate showed they were laughing at that.
I'd say if they're not laughing and they get kicked in the head show,
the con uh,
taekwondo guys Quando Muay Thai guys were,
you know,
he owns a karate schools is a full taekwondo guy.
He's a black belt under master Bill Clark.
Yeah.
And a real good one too.
The way he throws those kicks very taekwondo.
Like where he's got no chambering.
Yeah.
There's no step before he throws that cat laugh at that guy's,
yeah,
I've had him wrestlers.
Yeah.
I sleep on it and we'll look it up.
Edson Barboza landing that we'll kick.
You're starting to see all these,
these techniques now our land to get now Vitara at 35 years of age at 36 years
of age,
whatever he is,
there's all of a sudden a taekwondo black belt.
He's thrown wheel kicks,
head kicks.
He had kicked Bisbing.
It's like,
what the hell man,
the fucking head Dan Henderson fight vitro that just fought Dan Henderson.
That was like,
we were watching me like,
is he fucking getting better?
Is he better somehow or another?
I mean,
chuck fought him back in 2001 right.
What was,
when was that?
UFC 37 and a half.
Yeah.
I don't remember.
2002 it was the first one I ever commentated was chuck on Best Day.
It was like best damn sports show.
One of those things.
They held the fights and v tour back then.
Well,
I mean we're still worldclass.
He was still fighting against guys like chuck.
And then you look at him today and he's actually better all those years later.
This is him against Luke Rockhold.
I mean Jesus Christ.
And that's against Luke Rock.
Look at this shit.
And I guys got sweet.
This wheel kick is man.
I mean,
you would never believe that he wasn't,
uh,
like a lifelong taekwondo students.
Ridiculous fucking athlete.
He has his and then I don't,
I mean,
I don't think he's necessarily better than he was way back then.
He's a lot different because then he had a different,
like that blitz he had was,
was worldclass.
Yes,
no doubt.
I said now Vandelay fight.
He's much more well rounded now.
Yeah.
Look at this shit man.
Who the fuck saw that coming?
The guy throws it two times in his career.
Both in one fight.
Yeah.
He's,
he's definitely a much more well rounded fighter than he was.
And he's in look,
go back to him when people were thinking it was over with him when he was
fighting soccer.
Robyn pride.
Remember that fight?
They were like,
it's over for Vituro.
It's done.
You know,
he breaks his hands too easy.
He,
you know,
gave up against Sakharova.
He's been through a ride.
Bet You.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You carry so much stuff for folks who don't know.
His sister was kidnapped and murdered and it was murdered,
kidnapped,
and they found her.
No,
no,
she's murdered.
Yeah.
No,
she was murdered.
It's terrible.
Terrible,
terrible story.
I didn't know.
And yeah,
it was a horrible story and that haunted him for a long time,
man.
But whatever the reasons are he,
it seems like now at this stage of his career,
here's him against Sakuraba.
I mean,
this is just a totally different guy than the guy we're seeing now.
Sakharova beat his ass soccer.
Raba where the hell is he?
He's done.
I know too many.
But that Melvin man who fight,
did you see that?
No.
Jesus would pull up Sakuraba versus Melvin Manhoef.
Melvin Manhoef one of my all time favorite fighters because the guy win,
lose or draw came in growing missiles at you knocked out Mark Hunt in the
fucking first round.
Yeah.
Fatah in the kickboxing about knocked the or no,
it was MMA.
Mark on was like shooting it for the take down and he uh,
he caught him and knocked him out.
He,
he's just a wild,
crazy fucking fighter.
He's from England or something.
He's from Holland,
classic Dutch kickboxer and super ridiculously built just to fucking freak
athlete and he put a horrendous beating on soccer raw.
But it was one of the last beatings of soccer I was career.
It's like the Japanese,
they threw him in like,
it's like,
oh yeah,
they threw him in to that.
Like,
remember that vendor lay [inaudible] seven,
they just kind of learn a man over and over his Melvin Manhoef.
You've seen this guy fight before,
right?
Where's the gladiator trunks?
He's such a destroyer and he's a guy who's a do or die guy.
Like Robbie Lawler knocked him out.
He was going after Robbie Lawler and Robbie Lawler caught him and put him in
dream time.
But look at this horrendous beating.
Once he got soccer Robert Down,
and this was soccer.
Robert just couldn't do it anymore.
You know,
there was just nothing left.
His knees were all completely wrapped up like a mummy and look,
man,
hope is just fucking hammering him,
throwing his guard to the side,
like it's nonexistent laying on top of them and just pounding on them.
I mean just these hammer fists while he's out cold,
ruthless,
ruthless shit.
Yeah.
And then he took a lot of those,
you know,
look at this.
Jesus Christ gave his fucking head kick.
God Damn.
Matt Hoof is a monster.
That whole team,
Mike's gym and Holland.
Poof.
What a group of savages like Badr Hari Him.
He's got a,
he's got Allister for awhile actually.
From what I understand Allister,
his training and Thailand.
Oh yes.
For this upcoming fight with mirror,
which should be very interesting to see how that goes.
It looks like he lost a lot of weight too.
They said they had a photo of them are recently online and it looks like,
like he's lost a massive amount of mass.
I can't as many.
Five chuck.
He could barely make 200 pounds.
Yeah,
he had a Hartwell two oh five two or three though.
It wasn't pride.
I think I'll go with one 99 but I think he had a hard time making two oh five I
gained the weight.
Yeah.
Really?
I'd thought it was the opposite.
What I had always understood was that hey yeah he got better when he stopped
cutting weight cause cutting weight to make two or five was apparently brutal on
him cause he was always gas out
of the way I remember it.
Oh okay.
Yeah.
I remember him being super lanky and skinny and barely making be able to make
two or five.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Like this is like when he fought chuck.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Cause there was a whole weird way in process and cause this isn't it.
Everyone's different.
Yeah.
Those are the vendor lay days too,
man.
Ooh God.
Like the Vangelis stopped rampage.
The Vandelay stopped.
Sapora Sakharova here was a guy that even though I love martial artists and guys
who show a lot of respect and bow to each other and you know,
and then go at it demanded.
I didn't want none of that shit.
It's,
no,
it was,
he was a wild dog who's coming at you like a,
like a demon?
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
I mean,
to be honest though,
I see him,
I see that martial arts and name it might,
he might not have brought it out in the,
in the,
in the ways.
Um,
but I,
I actually saw it,
I even saw it in,
um,
rampage,
it a rampage to me,
rampage through for the persona of the camera and stuff.
And sometimes off camera,
I guess.
Well,
there was actually a camera because the whole truck thing,
I don't remember that.
Remember that truck thing when he had too many energy drinks or something?
Yeah,
yeah.
He went crazy.
But I,
even those days I just always saw him as I saw through,
you know,
that,
and I just saw him as a very respectful guy.
I always did.
Yeah,
and I agree.
He's,
you know,
he talks a lot of trash and he's smart and he knows how to promote fights in
that regard.
But yeah,
he's always been a very easy to talk to guy.
This is very few
guys that aren't in the,
in the MMA,
in the MMA world,
you could think of many boxers.
Like that guy that threw the chair at the referee who is that guy threw the
chair,
he's like hit a referee or something.
And was recently,
there was a while ago and he just fought recently lost again,
I forgot his name.
His Dad used to train him,
I forgot his name,
but I mean a boxing.
It just seems like it just didn't have that martial art edge.
And I can think of so few MMA guys,
like when I go to the UFC and it's just,
it's just being around these guys,
it's just,
they're so nice and respectful and just like all of them,
it's like you're being at some kind of happy party camping,
like your leg at a conference full of happy,
respectful people.
And it's like,
I don't,
I can't think of many that aren't what it,
what is the general feeling amongst the fighters that you're involved with about
TRT?
Um,
about my guys.
No,
not even,
you know,
about how they feel about it in general.
Like what's the general,
is there a,
is there a general consensus or,
I think it's now because it's now legal and whatever powers to be made it legal
for whatever crazy reason.
Um,
I think it's a lot of the guys just think I need it to stay competitive.
Just like probably most other sports.
But I wish it wasn't because there was a lot more fun without it.
It's kind of,
to me,
it's almost like the weight cut thing.
The weight cut thing is just gone.
I mean it's gotten crazy with weight cuts,
rehydration,
Ivs.
I mean it wasn't like that before.
It is strange,
um,
in the amount that they're losing.
It's just staggering.
Some guys just losing 30 pounds,
35 pounds and they're fighting at one 70.
Yeah,
they're way over 200 pounds for,
they start their car.
I put,
I put six bags and the guy once after Wayne,
I mean that's a lot.
And you could just see him on the bed after the way and just looked like a
skeleton and just so lethargic and then,
and then like two bags in and he's like coming to life and then like six bags
later,
he's like dancing around,
dancing around and he's like a regular guy again.
It's just so unhealthy.
It's just,
it's crazy electrolyte.
You know,
you throw your body into this crazy electrolyte imbalance and it's like,
I mean,
your whole electrolyte is a,
is a,
you know,
not only does it affect your acid base,
you have all that alkaline acid and he,
and,
and it also affects the electrical wiring and you're in your body because that's
what makes your electric wiring work,
you know,
and you have a really important electric wiring between your Aav node in your
sinus node,
in your heart.
And if that electrical doesn't happen,
every single beat,
it's not going to beat,
you know,
so it's such a fun and your brain is all electricity.
So to throw that off just to cut weight and you do because you know you have the
electrons of the,
you know,
yeah.
The potassium,
the chloride,
the magnesium that,
you know,
it's just,
it's a crazy thing that people put themselves in such harms way to make weight
because they want to be competitive to fight the next day in such another
dangerous sport.
And they're both becoming almost equally dangerous.
And now you throw TRT into that mix and that was becoming a whole different
sport.
Yeah.
That weight cutting things a real issue that doesn't seem to have a,
an easy solution.
I think it does.
What's easy solution?
Wayman the day of the fight.
Wayman walk right when they walk in.
Yeah.
But what if someone doesn't make the wait?
What are you going to do?
Like there's a lot of guys like Diego,
Brent Al's last fight.
Yeah.
Perfect example.
Him and Dustin Poirier kid just didn't make Wayne,
he was way over.
So what do you do that,
what happens there?
What did they do while they let them fight and he got,
but too many guys are going to take of that and they're gonna come in
heavier than their opponent.
Not they lose 20 pounds or 20% each time.
I mean,
that could be a solution.
Have the guy who doesn't make the way,
but it's still,
if the guy just keeps winning because he's not cutting weight and you are
cutting weight and you're getting skinnier and he's not and he's coming in full
and healthy,
it just seems to be an unfair advantage to a person who's not like thinking
evenly.
It doesn't,
it doesn't even care about the anytime of the day,
day before the day of the day of.
But I'm saying day off when Waylon Day off.
But,
but too many people would be like,
yeah,
I guess it didn't make weight,
whatever.
And they'll come in not weakened at all.
Right.
So,
but then,
but then the guy will step in the ring that made the weight.
He'll be two oh five and the average isn't like that Diego Guy,
the six he was six pounds or five pounds.
What was he,
how many?
Who's,
I think it was at least five pounds.
I mean for that weight class.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Actually I think he was 53 so I believe he was eight pounds over.
But he had had been in a car accident or a bunch of issues,
so there was a lot of things wrong.
So if the,
so a guys,
which is the average and even guys get cut the 20% a pound or a half pound,
that's what I mean.
It's more,
that's when they usually over there over by a pound or half pound.
So you,
so it's this exact same,
if it'd be the same the day of or the day before he walks in the cage a pound
over,
he gets 20% and the other guy wait ways then a pound less.
He's still only outweighing and buy a pound.
Yeah,
I could see you giving them maybe like five pounds if they're going to do it the
day of,
if it looks like they have to fall on a five,
five pound radius or a ratio or it could be,
or maybe more per like if you,
if you,
if you're a half pound to a pound and a half it's,
it's x amount of percentage and it could go up accordingly.
Yeah.
The real worry that people have is that on the day of the fights that people
would lose weight anyway.
It's still dehydrate themselves and not really have enough time to properly
rehydrate and then it can be really dangerous because most of like the really
severe injuries that have happened inside a boxing rings,
especially most of them have taken place in the lighter weight classes because
there's increased danger because of dehydration.
Right.
Cause the balances is more.
Yeah.
What do you tell your guys?
Do you ever like a cutoff where they will,
you don't want them losing any more weight than this?
Um,
yes and no.
I mean more,
most of my guys are pretty good about it.
I don't have too many crazy wait cutters.
Um,
but I mean,
to be honest,
you know,
I try to train him and I,
and I try to direct them in a lot of ways,
but to me that's a really personal thing and I can't get in their body and feel
what they're,
you know,
how much they're hurting and how much weight and how their body feels.
So like,
I knew how much I had to cut when I was fighting,
but I don't want to go into their body,
you know,
and say,
you can't do this.
And some guys just look,
you know,
a lot worse off than they are.
And some guys don't that bad often
are.
So it's hard.
It's a hard one.
I mean,
so they're grown,
man.
They've been doing most of them.
I've been doing it a long time,
so I let them kind of dictate.
If I see something crazy,
I'll say something.
But,
you know,
do you have any female fighters?
No.
No,
no.
I have in the past.
I'm not crazy about it at all.
In what way?
Um,
I mean,
um,
without selling sounding chauvinistic.
Um,
too late.
No,
I think like this sport,
like,
um,
like my daughter was a basketball player and she got a scholarship to college on
basketball and did great and she was one of the best basketball players for
girl.
You know,
and you can say that for a girl because when they play next to the guys,
you know,
they're not,
it doesn't look anything like the same thing except when she played her name's
Jelly bean and she was great.
I'm going to get so much trouble.
But when you watched two girls fight,
there's no difference.
These fricking girls are,
are our animals and they're great and they're their hearts.
I mean,
they're getting fight of the nights and they're fricking fighting,
but,
but when they get cut,
I mean,
when I,
it's just,
it's,
it's a different,
we're different.
I mean,
we're different gender and,
and it's more acceptable for a mantic to have his scars in his face,
you know,
the call flyers and stuff,
but mainly like the scars all over the,
the flat nose.
It's just more acceptable for,
you know,
for society.
I don't think it will be.
So when you have now the girls fighting when they're retiring,
I don't think you'll have a whole different,
um,
you know,
class of girls that are,
that are scarred up and stuff.
I'm that,
that would bother me if,
if,
if a girl came back and she was one of my fighters and she had a cut it,
I would just throw the towel in.
I just,
I just hate that.
I hate to see that.
And that's chauvinistic,
but sorry.
But the way they fight is unbelievable.
I mean,
these girls are every bit as good.
you know what I mean?
You like when you watch most sports and then watch a guy play it.
It's different sports,
you know?
But when you watch the group,
two girls find some of these girls and then watch two guys fighting,
it's just they have longer hair and it's still there.
I mean,
they're that good and we should too.
Ain't Ronda Rousey was an amazing class.
Dot.
Yeah.
And the other girl that's wild and fun.
And they're,
so,
their,
their skills in their heart is unbelievable.
But I just don't like the cuts and the damage that's going to,
I totally understand where you're coming from.
Uh,
yeah.
I,
for whatever reason,
except it easier when I see it on the mat as well.
Yeah.
I'm accepting it as when I see women busted up mean it is a part of what it is.
But if I saw like a really deep gash,
like I've seen like,
like Marvin Eastman or like maybe some of the other guy,
like some people have had some pretty bad gashes inside the octagon.
If that's a girl,
that's going to be interesting how people accept that culturally,
you know?
Yeah.
And then culturally,
you know,
after I left after a career's over,
I mean,
I mean it should
be known as some badass former fighter chick.
Yeah.
Some people liked that shit.
They probably,
well they like,
so we can do is like girls with tattoos
all over their bodies and some on their face and yeah,
I like that too.
So they might be scarred,
let's character and a woman John Hackleman.
Yeah,
that'd be kind of make a little shower chauvinistically but Nah.
Well,
you know,
you,
uh,
I was fucking seven years old when you were a referee in fights.
Yeah.
I've been in this business a long time.
I remember cutting weight when I was cutting weight and I was like,
I didn't know how to cut weight and I didn't have a meet coming up.
I didn't have,
I didn't have a guy like me coming up.
I was just like,
okay,
I read a book,
I do this.
So I started cutting weight.
You know,
you cut weight usually 24 hours out.
Okay.
And then you start drying out and you,
that's when your water intake goes down and you're,
you start sweating out.
You know,
it's not never more than 24 hours or you're not going to,
you know,
I didn't know that.
I was like,
I was like a week out and fucking wearing plastic suits and a down jacket,
you know,
jogging down the down the beach trying to cut my weight.
I was like,
I didn't know any different.
A lot of people did it that way for a long time.
A long time.
Yeah.
It just has to be starved themselves up to the fight.
And,
uh,
and we'd be wearing combat boots and,
and you know,
this is,
yeah.
So I didn't have a meet coming up,
but,
but that's,
that's just the way we did it back home.
You're a,
you're training methods.
Like where did you learn all these different things that you,
you like you're famous for having guys do a lot of like manual labor type stuff
and carry rocks and a fucking wheelbarrow and run up hill with it.
And where'd you,
where'd you come up with this idea?
This,
these routines?
Hmm.
I've been doing them for a long time.
Um,
I think just,
I've always had that old school chauvinistic.
I'm just an old school guy,
you know,
even when I was younger and,
uh,
um,
kind of like the rocky three,
you know,
like a,
and I actually have a rocky three experience where I was training hard.
I was like that rocky guy and knocking my guys out.
And then,
and then I got,
I got married to an older woman who was,
um,
much more,
uh,
more refined and she lived in Woodland Hills,
the suburbs,
and it went from ghetto van eyes.
Um,
a really bad place event.
I'd Delino Street.
Um,
so she cultured you in the little soft,
a little soft.
I would do my workouts here in woodland hills.
It might even still be here.
Racquetball world.
I don't know where that is.
Anyway,
I do my workout on the stairmaster and I was like trained for this guy and his
name was,
uh,
he,
his name was Charlie Archie.
They call him mister c.
He had a Mohawk and I got set up to fight him.
He,
he outweighed me by 31 pounds,
but we thought we'd take them anyway.
And my trainer,
uh,
I was training at the jet center with Benny.
The jet.
Your kitties.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
And um,
I just went in there like smiling and training at the,
you know,
the thing.
And I went in ring instead of being eye of the tiger,
I went over,
shook his hand,
you know,
and he dropped me with a body shot.
Wow.
And I got up and we,
we battled for a little while.
I dropped him and he dropped me in another body shop.
Cause once you get hit with a body shot and it's,
you're pretty much,
I mean if the guy knows how to do it,
unless you are tour Gaudy,
you know,
so I think he dropped me three times and two rounds and the referee finally stop
it.
And,
um,
and I just remember just thinking,
I had the tiger,
I got,
I lost my,
the tech.
And I remember thinking that and thinking I got soft.
And so I went back to my old gym,
I swept back to hardcore training and I got a rematch with him and I ended up
fighting him twice more,
uh,
and beat him twice.
But,
uh,
um,
it's that I always had that hardcore eye of the tiger,
you know,
running the train tracks,
be tough guy,
you know,
just,
it's kind of,
you know,
a lot of it's kind of outdated and stuff,
but it seems to work for my guys outdated in what way?
Outdated in the way the current science of physical conditioning approaches.
It doesn't that shit alter all the time.
It changes.
There's been so many things and I,
I'm,
I'm a firm believer in progression and learning new techniques like in the old
pit,
you know,
I mean,
I came up from a martial art back in Honolulu,
Hawaii called Kaji Kempo
karate,
judo cook,
Kempo and boxing.
And it was a hardcore art formed in Hawaii by five guys in 1947 mainly for
street fighting.
And it was,
uh,
it was built that way,
um,
and it was pretty hardcore,
you know,
growing up in Hawaii,
white kid,
you know,
kill Holly Day,
et Cetera.
So I wanted to be a tough gal.
Leaf of people don't know is what Hawaiians call white people.
It's usually fucking Holloway.
How the pride Tattoo.
But Holly Pride Tattoo,
which didn't go over,
but um,
but they don't like,
you know,
but you know,
so I have how the pride and definitely Hawaiian roots.
I love the islands and I love Hawaii,
but it wasn't easy growing up there.
It wasn't,
I mean,
I didn't come from a ghetto,
you know,
my dad was a hardworking newspaper writer and my mom was a great,
stay at home mom and,
um,
had a lot of love from my parents.
But growing up in Hawaii,
they do not like how these,
and,
you know,
going to school in Hawaii,
it was usually fucking Holly,
this fucking Holly that go back to the mainland,
how they give me lunch money,
how they,
what the fuck you looking at how they,
you know,
so there was a lot of that.
So I started training really early and it was a hardcore art.
Um,
and,
and uh,
I always stuck with a lot of those old training things,
training principles and training techniques and stuff.
And I,
those kind of stayed with me.
Even though things have comics,
things have gone.
I always knew that,
you know,
the old,
old school training techniques weren't going anywhere.
And,
uh,
so I go back and forth with them,
and they seem to work for me.
And,
uh,
and then I got,
I got,
um,
introduced to crossfit,
and like the early two thousands and I got to be good friends with,
uh,
Greg Glassman,
the owner.
And we came up together with cross pit because we thought,
you know,
cross fits great,
but we should,
yeah,
I wanted it specific for my fighters and my students.
So we started cross pit and,
um,
so it's like crossfit with more of a martial art feel and,
and I consider our system crossfit.
And um,
so that,
you know,
there's the wheel barrels and stuff.
What do you do specifically?
You have wheelbarrows,
you fill them with rocks,
you put weights in them.
Like what do you do?
Um,
um,
I put weights in them because I want to know what they way.
So,
um,
I usually,
there's different workouts I do with them,
but they're going up a hill because I live on a hill.
Um,
so it's,
it's different weights for different exercises.
Some are shorter Tabata sprints,
20 seconds on,
10 seconds off.
So you do use scientific training principles is a very good protocol for
conditioning.
Yeah.
And for people listening to this ta be a ta first found out about it,
cause my friend John Rollo,
he started using it.
Did,
it really helps a lot.
It does.
And,
and it was his foreign by some Kenji Tabata,
some Japanese,
uh,
exercise physiologists,
um,
who came up with that and he's,
he,
he proved it in his,
you know,
anybody can do their own tests.
But he proved that by doing these 22nd on a ten second off protocol,
only eight times,
that's four minutes.
Um,
and then he would have this other group,
Group B do a five mile run every day.
And then he proved that his,
uh,
his four minute tabata protocol would get in better shape than these five mile
runners every day.
So whatever,
whatever,
whatever that works or not.
I do my Tabatas.
Um,
I probably do a couple of workouts every week and I throw tomatoes in and I
think it's a good,
does something about,
um,
those old school strength and conditioning drills,
like manual work type things,
like the rocky three scenario he's running or was it rocky four ways in Siberia
and he's carrying logs around.
Yeah.
What does,
what is it about those old school training methods that are so appealing to us?
I think,
um,
yeah,
I think we're wired,
you know,
in our,
in our DNA,
you know,
are,
we're,
we're wired to be,
you know,
our,
our endocrine systems and all of our,
you know,
we're,
we're wired to be either fight or flight.
Right?
Isn't that what I mean?
So are,
and,
and
flight is running and then fight.
It's fighting.
So that's how we're wired.
I mean,
so we could play basketball and that's great and run around and,
you know,
throw the ball and stuff.
But I mean,
we're wired to fight and we're wired to run and we're wired to be strong and
we're wired to be,
you know,
we're wired to carry
boulders in this.
No,
that my point,
I feel
like,
like when you saw like George Foreman when he made his comeback,
uh,
one of the things about George Foreman's training routine was he had really
unorthodox methods.
Like you would take a jeep and strap it to him and pull it and he'd just be this
big giant guy pulling a fucking jeep behind him.
He also did a lot of manly shit.
Like he chopped a lot of wood,
you know,
chopped a lot of logs,
swung and acts all the time and swinging an ax.
It's like basically a crossfit type move.
I mean,
it really is like a really good strength and conditioning move for your whole
body.
But it's also manly.
He's out there getting the fucking firewood chopped up.
He's a man.
He's getting his work done.
There's something appealing about a guy out there in the snow chopping wood as
opposed to some Fufu with tights doing crunches in the gym with his feet up in
the air.
You know,
his little,
a little fucking baby socks on.
If there's something better about a guy smashing would with a fucking acts,
right.
It's more manly.
Hell yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
we do that.
There's a guy named Cameron Hanes and he's a,
like a famous bow hunter and a,
he also trains for bow hunting.
Gets in like really good shape for a lot of people that don't realize when these
guys go bow hunting,
they have to carry giant chunks of meat down hills.
So if you shoot an elk,
like you have to stuff your pack with like 150 plus pounds and make it down a
mountain or make it up a mountain,
you might have to go to the top and then go over.
Like these guys have to get in some serious shit cause they get their,
bring their meat back from where do you have to if you shoot an animal.
Okay.
Like if you go,
uh,
doing like some camping and bow hunting,
you make a camp and then you got to go into the woods and find the animals.
They're not going to come to you.
So you have to walk miles in.
Then you shoot one,
well,
it weighs 1200 pounds,
John Hackleman and you're gonna have to get that fucking thing back seven miles,
nine miles to your camp.
And it might take you three days to do it where you're all day.
All you're doing is walking to the body,
cutting a hundred pounds of meat off,
putting it in a backpack and walking back to the camp again over and over and
over again and trying to fill the truck up though.
This guy,
Cameron Hanes,
he trains for that.
Like he gets in shape for it.
He takes a giant rock,
130 pound rock,
puts it in a backpack and walks up to the top of a mountain.
It's one of the most ridiculous things I've ever seen on youtube.
It's fantastic.
But he has the meat we,
he was pretending to meet.
He throws a rock.
He does this to get his meat is exactly getting Vaughn's.
No,
he likes to do,
you don't get elk at Vons.
He's a hunter.
Well,
he likes,
I think he likes the,
the support of it because like I said,
the challenge,
but is it a competition or just,
well,
yes,
because of the,
it's one way competition.
You're,
you're competing for the officer,
the elks life.
And if the elk winds,
it gets to run away and dodge that Arrow.
But if it doesn't smell you in time or doesn't hear you step on a branch,
then you put an Arrow through,
it's hard and you get to eat it.
That's the competition.
Okay.
I mean,
you wouldn't think it's a sport,
but you have to be in fucking ridiculous
shape to do that.
But this guy,
this old school training method,
it's very appealing.
Like,
here's a rock in his backpack.
He could've had weights,
you know,
it could have had 45 pound plates on his back and stacked it up to,
130 pounds.
Nope,
no,
no.
He has a fucking rock.
Just a giant boom.
And he puts it a backpack,
throws it over his shoulder and walks up to the top of a mountain.
There's something about that that's more appealing for some reason to men than
seeing a guy do some squats and a gym wearing some [inaudible] sneakers.
You know,
getting on that Smith machine where it's all nice and smooth and doing some
squats.
I'm not doing weights anymore.
I'm going to put fucking rocks now.
I will be a fucking wimp if I put raw I to go rocks in my fucking wheelbarrows.
It's not a bad idea.
No,
because it'll give them more of a,
I feel.
Yeah.
Just way the rocks.
There's something to manly is fuck about moving rocks.
Chopping Wood.
Get them a big heavy ass acts.
Don't do that because when guys get tired,
you don't want to fucking accident like of their knee off fat.
What about some fat naked chick?
No barrel.
No.
Put her in the wheelhouse.
Christ hook.
I got confused.
So what are you going to do to her?
Yeah,
I don't think that's a good idea.
There's not a lot of motivation there for anybody.
Not for her.
I guess for her it would be a lot of fear.
Yeah.
You know,
maybe that I'm motivated to lose weight,
but I doubt it probably was like six traumatizor have through a pork out.
You've just fat shamed.
Do you know that
it's of that,
you know,
my son's fighting Friday in la.
Yeah.
You're excited about shrine auditorium?
Is it kickboxing or is it MMA?
What does the organization,
it's the RFA.
Oh,
that's right.
I'll get sworn in.
As far as organization,
do they,
are they still on access TV or they have an events on access TV?
I hope they do.
I,
that's one of the things I loved about HD net when it was HD net.
You know,
I just love that they have so many fights on HD fights and they have them on all
the time,
all day,
all the time.
So many fights over and over to so many good fights on Hg net and then the boss
route and show the him and uh,
Kenny Rice,
a lot of MMA on that channel.
It's a good show.
Yeah.
I hope a RFA is still a with them.
I'm not sure if they are,
but a,
what is it like having your son fight?
Is that weird?
Yeah,
because the way I feel about fighting and he's 32 mm.
So I mean,
he's only a second fight pro fight.
How long has he been training his whole life?
He's a train set as a kid,
you know,
basically five years old,
six years old.
He's been training,
but he just never really wanted to focus on the structured fighting.
Always been a fighter,
always been a great martial artist.
Um,
they just,
you know,
I want to fight Pronoun.
I was like,
really?
Okay.
Alright if you want.
But he did.
So he did his first fight.
It was as far as his first fight,
it was over really quick.
And uh,
he's six,
four
one 85.
Wow.
That's a lot of reach.
Yeah.
I have to tell people at home people,
you know,
um,
maybe you've never sparred even before,
really have no idea what a massive advantage along reaches.
It's got a huge,
huge advantage,
you know,
in the ability to touch a guy when he can't touch you.
Yeah,
I see it that way.
But then I see the other way too
where a guy who's got short arms,
like a Tyson just gets in and then
now all of a sudden the advantage turns that quick.
So I think if you know how to cut off the ring slash cage,
um,
cause I think if you did it,
if you did a study,
I don't know if the like the heavyweight champions and,
and I don't know if the,
the height would be that huge
have,
I think it's pretty big.
You know why?
Because I think that if you have the height,
you don't necessarily require big power.
Right.
You know,
like I think John is a tremendous athlete and one of the greatest talents to
ever fight in the UFC.
But if you had to describe John with one word,
it wouldn't be power.
You know,
he hits hard,
no doubt about it and I'm sure he's getting better at hitting hard,
but it's,
it's a different kind of hard then like a chuck hard and you starches all these
guys with one shot and you realize like these guys got hit.
Like they got hit by a sniper,
boom.
He had someone there stiffening up.
You don't see that type of power with John.
Yeah.
And I think,
but you think the height,
but I think that if you have height you can get away with more.
Whereas if you are short and you got short limbs,
you better be able to do a lot of damage with every shot you land once you get
inside.
Like Tyson style.
Yeah.
You're like,
that was the thing about Tyson.
It wasn't just that he was,
you know,
short do,
you could do damage when you got inside.
It's just the,
what he could do in a short amount of time was so tremendous because of the
amount of power yet.
But if you had a guy like Pernell Whitaker that was like a short guy,
but he was short and stocky,
but he had that kind of style where it's like very slick and hard to hit but
really didn't put you out with one shot.
I think it'd be a way less effective body size,
body type.
Hmm.
Such as thinking.
No,
I mean,
I mean a lot of,
I mean obviously it's um,
uh,
a common way of thing because they say,
you know,
you've reached your advantage.
They never say reached disadvantage.
Exactly.
But I just never found it that way.
But I,
I just think it's the skill of different things.
What do you think on the ground?
Do you think height or,
or,
or plays a part in triangles,
right?
But what Doris Doris was,
what about limbs for,
for getting true?
Yeah,
the shorter guy.
Well,
um,
I think,
uh,
it's harder to tuck yourself flat when you're defending armbars.
It's harder to not give up on buses and all that room when you get these big ass
fucking stork arms.
You know,
there's all room where guys can slip,
slip arms and grab hooks.
But there's also so much leverage in long arms and long legs.
I think more of an advantage,
too long limbs than anything.
Like you look at a guy like Hodgett Gracie clearly uses his limbs to his
advantage.
Uh,
Braulio esteem.
Another guy,
long guy clearly uses that to his advantage.
Like broadly,
especially one of his,
uh,
signature moves is this sort of upside down triangle.
When guys are like trying to pass his garden,
he slap a triangle on you and it's like really weird,
awkward way.
And I think that you,
uh,
you know,
you don't necessarily get that as much with guys with the shorter limbs because
it's just not available.
It's hard for like a guy like me with a short stubby legs.
I can't,
there's certain guys that is not going to triangle them.
Um,
cause I'm never going to get it around the back of my knee.
You know,
a guy who was like 260 pounds,
most likely I'm not going to try and go on the angle that I'd have to cut to
actually lock that off would be so severe.
It'd be really,
really hard to pull off in a guy who knows what's going on.
Whereas a guy,
I'm like,
hundred Gracie,
those fucking legs are so God damn long.
You get inside of his guard,
all studies moving your route.
It's swipe and it's on you and there's nothing you can do to stop it.
It's just they're strong and they're long and the lever of those limbs,
cause I think it's a pretty significant advantage on the ground as well.
Yeah.
So I think,
I don't,
I've done or looked at it as one standing.
I just think because I think that guy gets inside a lot.
He's going to have the advantage of the guys outside and I just don't think
getting inside would be that much of a deal because there's a cage or a ring.
Right,
because you can't go.
Yeah.
You can't just keep moving.
If it was in a big opener auditorium,
like if guys fought on a basketball court.
Yeah.
That would be very different.
Completely different sport.
Yeah.
That's actually kind of a fascinating idea to have a,
a basketball court size,
like a basketball court sized room where a guy could just run around and you can
never get him up against the corner.
And then,
and then let's give the other guy the chance to listen.
I'm fighting the phone booth.
Yeah.
Take it one round in the basketball court.
One round at a phone booth
they had where you did one round point fighting
and then one round we could only touch the by like a karate point fight.
And then they put on gloves and then they did one round full kickboxing,
and then they went back and they put on any speak,
loves,
I think.
And then they did one round.
Anything goes.
Remember that?
That little guy used to do that?
Uh,
who I know Shonie Carter used to do that.
Tim?
Yeah.
It was called,
shoot,
I forget the name,
but it was,
came from Hawaii.
Uh,
uh,
basically karate roots.
And so the guys that did it were usually better strikers,
but uh,
but um,
that's interesting.
You remember a Draka?
Yeah.
These two have like kickbox and combined with [inaudible].
But you just take him down and then they had to get right back up.
Yeah.
That was weird.
Well,
that's what,
isn't that similar to what a Kung leading edge,
woosh you or whatever?
Um,
well,
yeah,
it's kind of did a lot of that.
The very similar stuff.
Yeah.
What did she,
what did they call it?
No,
no.
Woo Shu.
God Damn it.
What was it called?
Well,
she wasn't it.
I don't believe so.
I believe it was called that.
Um,
what would that,
what the hell?
I can't believe I can't remember this.
I have too much information in my head.
John Hackleman.
As I get older I feel like I'm getting stupider.
Sanshou San Shoe.
Do you meditate?
Yes.
You do.
I just have too much information,
too much coming in.
I forget.
But he was a very good wrestler as well,
so that was one of the reasons why he was good.
His kicking style,
which is so spectacular,
flamboyant.
One of the reasons why it's so effective as cousins wrassling was so good.
He could keep the fight standing and he,
you know,
he could take his leg when he throws a kick.
And first of all,
if you try and catch it,
you might get a broken arm.
And second of all,
if you do catch it as balanced,
as phenomenal.
What ever happened to him,
he just beat,
um,
rich Franklin.
He knocked out rich Franklin,
but he's got to move.
He couldn't one on right now in the UFC.
Oh,
okay.
[inaudible] overhand,
right.
Or a right hook.
There's a little while ago.
Yeah.
That's the last fight he's had.
He's busy.
He's got a lot of movie things going on.
Yeah.
I did a pretty big,
um,
uh,
science fiction movie.
What was that?
Pandora,
is that what it was called?
Let me see what the move film career,
here we go.
Powerful Wikipedia.
Penn dorm.
Yeah,
that was the movie.
If you never seen that movie before.
It's a really interesting movie,
man.
Really interesting science fiction movie.
And he plays this dude in the future that is a existing around all these,
uh,
freaky hybrid monster people that have been created there aren't doing your
ship.
Oh,
it was a good movie.
But is he good?
Yeah,
he's good man.
He's a good actor.
He's a good fucking actor.
And he does martial arts in the movie as well.
And realistic martial arts,
like,
you know,
he's doing,
he says he's a bad motherfucker.
Kang Lake.
These ain't Chuck's commercial.
Which camera?
Oh,
the bud light commercial.
Is it?
I mean like,
and,
and then watching a rampage on a team.
Yeah.
I these guys,
I mean,
I love to watch that because I mean,
it's not easy to read a script then try to portray something or else they actors
wouldn't make so much money.
It's not easy to do at all.
No.
It's like when people tell you to say,
okay,
act scared and then say this,
it's hard to do that with oncommand.
Yeah.
And I think chuck is,
I mean,
he's got that personality.
He's remember that he was on that talk show where he's playing with the dolls
and he loved to dress up dolls.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
What was it?
He did a great job that he was,
I mean,
he's so funny.
Well,
he can be himself.
You know,
some people panic when they say ready action and they have so much wrapped up in
who they are that they'd come off like fake and weird.
Yeah.
He's,
I think he's,
he's,
uh,
you know,
living in Calabasas living in that lifestyle.
I think he's going to take off in a second career.
You think so?
I do.
I can't.
I think he could.
I really do.
I think just being him in front of a camera with any,
in any background,
in any,
you know,
any way,
whether it be a movie or
Randy's doing really well is he?
Yeah.
Randy had a quite a few movies,
man.
He's in two of the expendables are three of the expendable Louise.
He's always got things going on.
Randy's always got something cooking acting wise.
I've never been a was a big fucking movies.
I know,
I've heard about it.
I never saw it.
Never saw it.
He's got a big part.
Is he working in a sense corner?
I'm not in the UFC.
His son's not in the UFC anymore.
Fine.
Um,
I don't know if he worked to son's corner.
I know there was a big issue though in the UFC that he couldn't work.
It sounds corny.
I know.
It's some crazy stuff.
Yeah.
You know what man?
I have,
Dana White is a very competitive guy and he has like very strong ideas about
loyalty and you know,
the UFC has everything to him and you know,
I'm a different kind of guy,
you know,
like I don't fault anybody for competing in another organization.
I don't fault anybody for,
you know,
I think the world's pretty big.
There's plenty of room living room for a lot.
And if the UFC wasn't using Randy and you know,
and he goes over and is on Bellator and he's coaching,
I honestly think it makes the UFC look better.
You know,
UFC champion is that you wanted to get this UFC champion on your show.
I think it's a free UFC ad.
I don't think it changes the ratings of the UFC or changes the ratings Abella
tour.
But what it does do is it gives Randy coture money.
You know?
I just think that UFC is fine.
It's not going nowhere,
you know?
And Dana,
it's like you're on my team or you're against me.
You know?
It's like,
yeah,
more like that by like that.
My team are against me.
Oh,
well listen,
this is a call all hypocritical.
It's coming because it's coming from me who,
if I leave the UFC,
I'm done.
Like I'm never doing this for somebody else.
I do this UFC or that's it.
I was going to say this,
but I,
I,
before even you and Mike,
I know I've told you this before.
I know it's probably like this,
you know,
it's getting tired.
I mean I have never,
I've been around combat sports,
like I said competitively since 74 I've never heard you'd be considered a color
commentator and he's the comic.
I've never heard such a good team ever,
ever.
I mean I can't even just watching the,
the,
those fights when you guys are are calling neck fights.
It's unbelievable watching this fight.
It's the best.
It's just the personalities and then,
and then throwing a Bruce buffer in for the announcing.
The combination is,
is it's,
it's actually magic and,
and between,
you know,
you guys calling the fights,
it's just such a perfect combination.
I mean it adds,
it adds to the UFC.
Well that's so kind of you.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate that coming from you.
That means a lot,
man.
You're,
you're very kind guy.
You've always been very
well.
You know that's true and it's,
it's really,
it's the DFC just happened to step up with with,
and then everything just seemed to fall into place.
I mean we got you guys calling it,
you've got Bruce buffer.
Then these,
the the matches and then the fighters and it's,
it's,
it's turned into,
you know,
just something that'll just,
it's great.
Do you think about Dana is,
Dana is the one who like this vision of putting this all together.
He's the one,
he's the one that got me into commentary.
If I,
if it wasn't for Dana White,
I never asked for this job.
I never pursued it.
I turned down pride.
They offered me the job of being the color commentator for pride.
I was like,
I don't want to do it.
I'm not going to Japan.
Thank you very much.
No thanks.
I can't do it.
I'm like,
I'm working too much as it is.
But when Dana said,
just do this one for me,
like UFC 37 and a half,
I'm like,
okay,
I'll do it.
You know,
I'd gone to a bunch of them and I would always do interviews for them and you
know,
talk to people about what I loved about the sport.
But I'd be in the audience when I was doing it and Dana,
he figured out that I would be a good guy for this.
But like most people would have never hired a guy who's never done any sports
commentary at all ever and take them and make them a color guy on television for
the first bout.
But this ridiculous.
But he's like,
you could do it.
And then I figured out how to do it along the way.
But the thing about like Goldberg and me,
it's like we've been doing it together for so long.
Like I could finish that dude sentences.
I know what he's saying before he says it.
He knows what I'm going to say most likely before I say it.
He knows when I'm saying things when I'm done.
We know,
like when each other wants to make a point,
we know when each other,
you know,
wants you to take over.
It's like we have this like smooth sort of like communication that you only get
from calling it a thousand plus fights together.
It's a long ass time.
Yeah,
I agree.
But I disagree.
I mean,
you could,
you could have two guys,
you could also have two guys that,
or to,
you know,
a guy in a woman in a marriage.
It can be married forever and it's just sometimes it's just not going to work.
That's true.
So I think at the chemistry and the,
I mean,
you have so much knowledge when you're watching it.
And I remember in the beginning I was thinking,
oh,
he's like grappler base.
He's a little,
but you know,
that's just me.
But,
um,
but you just have so much knowledge,
you know?
Um,
I mean,
you know,
so many of the,
because when it hits the ground,
you know,
obviously a lot of the guys are like,
you know the fans,
but you always like,
exactly.
You say,
what's exactly what's going to happen here?
What should happen here,
what might happen here,
and how this guy should do this.
And it makes it,
it makes it really easy to watch,
you know?
Well,
that's awesome man.
I really appreciate that.
It's fun to do.
You know,
I never thought I would ever be involved in any sports in any way,
shape or form.
It was never an ambition.
So the fact that it's so seamless and so easy to do,
but it's just really just because I'm honestly a huge student of martial arts my
whole life.
I always have been and always uniquely fascinated by new techniques and drills.
How a guy's getting over on another guy.
How guy did this,
when he should have done that.
Like,
I love what,
you know what I love?
I love watching dudes show real sneaky shit.
Like Tj Walberger you just see is not TJ.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
in,
uh,
Sacramento.
Yes.
God dammit.
Yeah.
He was the guy who looks like he's from,
he looks like he's from Boston,
but he's not Miller Miller,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Dillashaw Tj,
Tj Dillashaw.
Oh,
I brain's mush today.
Okay.
This is one of the worst brain days I've had in weeks.
I'm thinking it's,
it's trained right before I got here.
I'm exhausted.
So my fucking noodles not working so sweet.
But I'm Tj Dillashaw fought Mike Easton.
Yeah,
in Georgia last week.
The fucking kid was moving so good doing all this sneaky shit all he's like,
you think he's going for a take down?
He throws a head kick.
You think he's going for a punch?
He throws a knee.
He was doing all this really subtle shit as far as like his movement and the in
and out and moving from side to side,
avoiding the attacks of Easton,
but landing,
let consistent shots over and over again picking his style apart.
So interesting to see these kids like really evolve and grow.
And when I see a guy like Tj Dillashaw and I see him evolve and grow like that,
like that's to me one of my favorite things in the sport.
Seeing a guy who's like,
you'd see him on the ultimate fighter,
he's talented,
he's a raw young kid,
loses,
you know,
to a,
a really scary guy.
And Dodson.
I mean,
Dodson at that weight as a fucking demon.
He's a will of the wisp kids so fast and he can knock guys out,
which is a rare thing for 135 pounds.
And then he see Dillashaw go from that to just slowly but surely putting all
these skills together.
Now you're looking at me go,
this kid is a bad motherfucker and you're watching them grow right before your
eyes.
You watching him like step into his,
his future right before your eyes.
That's one of the most exciting things for me.
Talking to him.
He's like nicest kid in the world.
That's why it's so scary too.
It's like,
I mean,
you're talking to this guy like a um,
training with Steve.
Steve Mako.
You ever heard of them?
Yes.
Okay.
So he was over yesterday training and we're going over the hooks,
which you're going to do a left hook later.
Hope left,
took to your pads.
I really want us show you the leftover.
Okay.
Um,
it's my favorite punch.
but when I met him I thought,
you know,
hey,
what's up man?
How you doing?
He was the glove.
I thought he's a friend and lowers,
he looked like a,
as a you,
he looks like a Barney rubble on steroids,
bro.
What do you do?
And he's like,
Oh,
wrestled da Da da Da.
And I was like,
I dunno.
Wrestling.
So,
but then I find out along the way,
this guy is like a bad ass wrestler.
I mean,
he's like,
you know,
USA,
this entity,
this Aa,
this,
whatever.
And he's like the real deal because all the other UFC guys know him and it's
like,
it's scary because guys like that or Tj or this Guy Marcus Alameda here of him.
Marcos Almeida.
Yeah.
Some of the Jujitsu,
the same name or to,
or something is like,
wait,
he is,
they call him,
his nickname was like fat cheeks.
I don't know what in everything his name is Marcus,
all the Meta and he just won some
absolute something.
Well,
there's another guy named Marcus Alameda who's a singer.
Oh,
this guy is a Jujitsu guy.
Yeah,
here it is.
The world guy.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a couple of them.
He was like,
he was on the show with us.
Um,
the ultimate fighter,
cause we did season 19.
Um,
and I'm walking around with him.
I didn't know who he is.
I don't follow Jujitsu and you know,
a,
you know,
we're walking around in it,
somebody asked me,
Oh,
can I get a picture and this thing and he's like holding the camera and then we
go behind the scenes behind the,
you know,
the UFC,
the training rooms is,
one of the UFC is,
was,
was going on.
Um,
and that all the fighters know him.
It was like they're running up to them.
They want to take their picture with them.
And I was walking like,
go,
who are you man?
What do you,
what do you do?
I just do Jiu Jitsu and,
and I find that,
I look him up.
He's like the,
the,
like the world's Best Jujitsu Guy Right now,
or the wind.
He's one of the top guys for sure.
He just won a Abu Dhabi and the absolute division.
Yeah.
So,
so,
you know,
he had a draw with Heidrick Gracie in Metamorris,
so that's good.
That's pretty fucking impressive.
So is rapper one of the strongest grapplers on earth without a doubt.
One of the very best guys.
And when you,
and the thing about this sport,
like the boxers,
you know,
I hung around,
I grew up more boxing and hardcore Mahershala guys and that you could just tell,
but in this sport it's so scary cause like a guy like Steve Mako.
Yeah.
I mean you're going to go up to me to him,
you're in a bar,
you've had a few drinks and you're going to go up to him and say something.
You know,
if you don't do that,
yeah.
It's like [inaudible] or do you go to go up to someone like Tj Dillashaw and say
something big mistake.
Huge cheat me.
I got this guy named Castle Williams of fights.
Me 19 year old kid.
They looks like Bieber,
Justin Bieber,
and um,
he's one of my,
he's undefeated fighter fighting,
you know,
King of the cage and he's like,
he looks like,
like I said,
it looks like Dustin Bieber,
but he will take your head off and then throw you down and put you in some kind
of lock and lock something up until it breaks.
We'll Siler is,
oh my gosh.
Sweet looking kid.
Let me tell you,
I get nice nick next door neighbor boy.
Like no American kid.
Okay.
Siler.
Chuck clover.
Um,
all my fighters are great,
but these guys just before a fight,
you'll never think they're going to fight.
You think they're going to go to seven 11.
I mean like Siler before fight is,
is the absolute calmness guy I've ever seen before.
Fight.
He's in the dress room,
like I said,
playing video games with his opponent and they're laughing.
I've seen him fight before last.
He's in the,
he's in the,
in the dressing room with his wife who used to come into corner with them all
the time.
The last one she didn't,
but she usually does and they're playing like they're looking on like for cute
little stuff for the house and the Eggo,
Bro.
We got a warm up now.
He goes coach.
Okay,
like three more minutes.
Let me look at this.
And walking out to the cage,
he's just like you fighting Glover before he fought to Hoonah,
we're walking out and I'm like,
okay Bro,
I don't want you to slugging with this guy.
Why aren't you taking them down real quick?
And you know,
I'm going over this.
The thing is,
coach,
I got this,
I got this.
Then we get up right to the end and birch yelling and there's,
you know,
it's a massive UFC and,
and I'm so nervous and Glover turns to me right before we went to take the final
walk to the cage and he goes,
coach,
fuck,
I don't want to do this man.
I'm fucking scared.
I want to quit right now.
I don't want to fight.
But he didn't smile and he didn't look like he was joking.
What does the trainer do?
I'm not going to make him go out there.
I just don't want to do this anymore.
Coach and I looked at him,
I just didn't know what to say cause I'm joking.
Let's go out and he goes look to,
as I'm talking,
you need to relax my,
let's go have some fun.
So I mean it was just these guys,
they're just so cool.
These MMA guys is scary.
This is what over him looks like.
No.
Yeah,
he's,
he's lost a lot of weight.
He was down a little bit.
Huh?
He's lost a lot of weight.
I don't know how much,
but that's a good idea.
You know,
was carrying so much muscle around with them.
I mean you saw on the Travis Brown fight,
perfect example.
I mean he's all over charis bound in the beginning of the first.
He just couldn't keep up that pace.
She couldn't do it.
You think a lot of that's HGH as well as the TRT.
Who knows?
Scary one.
You do that well,
you know what it is,
man.
If you looked at how big he was when he was the k one Grand Prix champion,
the accusations were always there.
So then the accusations,
he tests positive.
So then when he tests positive and he has this excuse for it,
but then when he's not on the testosterone,
now he shows like low testosterone.
So I think he's trying to do it legitimately now.
But the problem is,
I think,
like you talked about before,
a lot of these guys,
they run the risk of screwing up their endocrine system by,
you know,
hyper juicing it.
And then they go back to trying to be natural.
And they're kind of at a big disadvantage.
If you go low,
if your,
if your testosterone is low,
I mean,
yeah,
it's easy if you're that big,
I mean,
your testosterone is low.
There's some fen feminine qualities that are kind of come in because that's what
happens.
I mean,
it's a competing estrogen,
you know,
cause we have estrogen as well.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
we don't,
we don't have nanograms like we do.
Uh,
you know,
we don't have nanograms of,
of,
of estrogen.
Like we do testosterone,
we have pico grams,
which is,
you know,
a trillionth of a gram,
but there's a lot less.
But when we start messing with that fine balance,
I mean there's,
I mean,
we're going to grow some boobs and a vagina and I'm just saying,
but think of Ronda Rousey,
who's feminine and Misha Tate is feminine,
but they're still fucking badass beasts.
You know,
they're still wicked fighters.
Okay.
What's,
how come a man,
when is it,
is competitiveness in the mind or do you think that the having the extra
testosterone,
the system actually does make you more aggressive,
make you more competitive?
That would never,
they'll never,
ever be discovered or proven unless they fight men.
Yes.
Women fight men.
How do you,
how do you figure that?
Well,
because if you're saying you're taking testosterone,
so yeah,
because they have,
you know,
a low testosterone,
they're women,
they have more estrogen,
but they're fighting each other,
which they look great fighting each other.
Just like when you ever watch a channel 34,
the Mexican channel,
you can watch two very mediocre Mexican boxers.
They're just,
they look,
they both look like to archer.
God,
he's there going,
I mean,
but then if you put them in with you,
put them in with the Mayweather,
they're going to look just like amateur.
So I mean as good as the girls are and they are fantastic.
I don't think they can ever compete because of the testosterone with men.
That's why they had that Fallon issue.
Yeah,
I agree with you on both counts.
I think that the,
um,
you know,
the idea that there,
that,
that it's somehow another equal.
So then it becomes a matter of like,
if a guy has a really low testosterone because of,
you know,
past steroid use,
do you think the guy should be allowed to compete?
Because if he has a really low testosterone and he's competing with guys like
Glover who are natural,
who are in really good shape,
it could be potentially like real dangerous.
Like he has a limit to his gas.
Right?
So,
and I've had this discussion with people that most people that disagree with me
and most people do disagree with me on most things for some reason.
Agree with you most of the time.
How about that?
Thank you.
I'm on your side.
Most people don't,
I mean it's like I get,
I,
I'm like every,
my political view,
I have every sports.
I mean they only agree with me on my left hook and my head kick.
Other than that,
they're like,
they disagree with almost everything I say.
But I think if the woman,
you know,
like the do the Fallon okay.
This,
how was it?
That was a big thing.
Yeah,
it was a huge thing.
I took a lot of heat from that.
Um,
if people thought it was being transphobic,
which I'm absolutely not,
I couldn't care less what you want to do.
I'm happy if you're happy.
But I think that the idea that you could be a man for 30 years and then compete
in mixed martial arts as a woman,
it's pretty preposterous.
It's,
it's actually,
it's ludicrous.
It's like I'm as gay friendly as as they come.
I mean,
I could,
uh,
if wasn't for that,
can I,
can I cuss on this?
If it wasn't for sucking cock?
Hmm.
Which I would probably be firmly opposed to,
I could probably be a gay guy because I'm sensitive.
I love chick flicks.
I hate watching fights when the guy hurts the guy.
I don't,
I,
you know,
I hate that.
So I,
but I'm not gay unfortunately.
Uh,
but I think that's,
I mean,
it's nothing to do with gay or straight.
No,
they'll tell you it is.
They're silly.
They're just being,
what they're doing is they are opposed to your,
your point of view and your point of view is that that's not a woman.
And they want it.
You'd accept her as a woman.
They want you to accept the fact that she has had a sex change and she's a woman
now.
And I say in all things except for that one.
And all things except for the bone structure is completely different.
It's been,
you're involved in a striking art where you're trying to give each other
concussions.
And I know for a fact there's some guys even that are just built in a way that
other guys aren't.
All right.
And when you see those two guys compete against each other,
the guy with the bones has a significant advantage.
Yeah.
But it's never usually as radical as the idea of a guy competing against a girl.
And so even if you change the hormonal characteristics of this person and make
them hormonally a woman,
the bone structure remains the same for 15 years.
They're talking about it like,
like how long it takes to lose the,
you know,
and d for bone density to start really decreasing to noticeable levels.
It takes a long ass time.
Well,
when the,
and when they say that,
just like the guy with the low t from,
from one hit in the head,
which he's a doctor,
he probably knows more than I do,
but I would,
I would like to disagree with it and see it.
Yeah.
I think what he's saying is it happens sometimes and he's dealing with those
people that it happens too.
If you get the broad range of people that have been hit in the head,
how many times does it happen?
Is it 1%?
If it's the only 1% think of how many people are coming to him with traumatic
brain injury that have low test.
But I'm thinking for,
so for the women,
I mean over 15 years,
I think you're still a man cause he'd been a man for 20 but whatever,
whatever the d series.
30 Huh?
30 30 30 years as a man and then a woman and then becoming a woman fighter.
It's like,
so it's so the t's lows lost.
She lost one of her recent fights,
but she lost to a woman who was just really fucking good.
Yeah.
You know,
and she just,
she's not really fucking good.
The woman she fought,
persevered,
got through it and finished her off.
You know,
it doesn't mean it's still not,
it's ridiculous situation.
Yeah.
Just because a woman figured out how to beat her,
what it means is that that advantage still wasn't enough for her to beat someone
better than her.
So do you think then,
I mean with that,
so the guy that does the testosterone when he's younger or when he's doing
steroids,
when he wants to be a body builder,
when he's younger or whatever.
So now he has a low t.
I mean,
is it fair,
shitty?
Is it fair to say you can't compete now because you're on TRT?
I think it is.
I think,
I think a lot of your past decisions in your life affect you and,
and if,
I mean,
why should that guy get to do it?
When this guy who said I wasn't he,
he wasn't doing testosterone,
why can't he do it?
I mean,
so I think that decision people that just the,
the disagreement I got was,
well,
why should you take that away from him from a mistake he made in the past?
I said,
well,
if he,
if he made another mistake in the past and now all of a sudden he can't vote or
he can't go to college because you didn't go to high school.
I mean,
he just can't.
There's certain things you can't do.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I see what you're saying.
Look,
if you're a felon,
you can't own a firearm and you can't be a cop.
No.
Now you'll never be a cop.
Should you take that away from this guy because he didn't make a mistake in the
past.
Sorry.
That's just the way it goes.
Yeah,
and that'll stop.
If there's a way to stop people from doing it,
that is the way,
right to say you.
You're,
you can't,
you cannot do,
you never take it now.
Yeah.
You can ever say is reserved for people who have a medical condition that didn't
abuse her father.
That's
if that's the case,
that's where [inaudible] comes into play.
That's where Vittoria it gets strange because Vito has been caught before.
Okay.
And,
and a lot of people do.
And there's a,
I mean,
so many people on it now.
It's not even,
I mean it's,
I,
I'd be willing to bet over 50% of the guys are doing it now.
It's probably lower,
but I don't,
I,
I think it's close to the heavier guys.
Do you have any guys,
you don't have to name names.
Do you have any guys that are on it?
No.
Is it because of your influence on them?
I have not never let my guys do it,
but now that it's becoming legal for my most competitive guys,
I'd have a real hard time looking at them in the face and saying,
sorry,
your dream to be at a title holder is going to be diminished because,
because of my,
my old fashions,
yeah.
Old fashioned ethics in my not too smart thinking but sorry,
that's just the way it is at the pit.
I've done a lot of things for my guys and to my thing,
you know,
to my guys and,
and I've,
I've,
I think I've closed some doors for him.
There's certain things I don't allow and I,
I don't think I would not,
I,
if,
if the UFC is going to say it,
you can do it now than I,
I couldn't look at my guy in there,
I'd say no.
Well I respect that.
I respect that honesty too.
Cause that's a very,
uh,
what you just gave is a all be controversial and honest response because that's
one of the things about you and your relationship with fighters that are really,
really respected.
You really care about those guys.
It's a very obvious,
too much.
So always very obvious.
There's some guys when you see them in their coaching fighters,
it's um,
it's,
you know,
it's certainly personal.
It's certainly emotional,
but not to the degree the degree is with you,
Eh,
these guys are,
yeah,
I think,
I think a lot of it has to my past and stuff.
But I mean I actually broke down after a fight once and I've always got real
nervous after fights by broke down after actually want a Glover's fights.
And,
and after the fight I was sitting in a corner and I was just couldn't stop
crying and I was just,
I can't remember.
He got hit,
he got rocked a little.
And then I dunno,
I don't remember.
I don't remember what site it was cause it just happens now.
Every fight almost.
Wow.
And I just remember my aunt and I was just thinking I don't,
I shouldn't be doing the same way.
I just,
I can't tolerate this watching my guys get hurt,
you know?
And then it happened real bad.
You'll Maldonado was it that fight?
Yeah.
So that was the second time then.
And he knew how mad I was after that fight.
I think he said something to the announcer right after the fight and he knew I
couldn't even talk to them.
I couldn't even talk to him for hours.
I have to fight cause he did that.
He dropped his hands.
He did that in a find the WC once he got caught and he went and knocked the guy
out right away.
And the first thing he did when he came back to the corner it was,
I'm sorry coach,
I know how you feel about that.
I know cause I just cause they know it's not a joke for me.
Trauma is no joke for me.
I agree.
And it's like,
I do not,
I will throw in the towel.
Like,
I mean,
I'll throw in the towel so quick that,
if my guy gets hurt,
the towel is going in like I did.
I mean like with chuck fought rampage,
you know,
I'm the first one,
he wasn't even really getting hurt,
but I just saw he was hurting inside.
He was,
he was stuck in a half guard.
He couldn't get up and he was exhausted and,
and it just broke my heart,
you know?
So it's like getting smashed with elbows.
Yeah.
But they're mostly to the body issues though,
right.
Rampage through some nasty elbows to the body.
That was rampage,
rampage Jackson and the pride days,
like when he slammed her Cardwell Rona got Dan,
was that hello?
A lot of that.
Then a little bit of that.
So there's a lot of that.
And then how do you know about that?
For sure.
No,
just I've heard.
Okay.
But,
um,
but then he said something on a show once where he was,
when I,
when guys say,
well,
I got a prescription,
or somebody said not too long ago,
you know about,
well this guy has levels way up.
But then they admitted that they had a doctor's prescription and did too.
Well,
rampage got testosterone replacement recently,
but as far as I know,
I don't know that he's ever said anything about using any sort of steroids in
the ass.
I think he was just cock strong is an unbelievably strong God.
I mean,
do you ever see videos of him wrestling in high school?
No.
Rampage when in high school was ridiculously strong.
Just lifting guys up and hurling them through the air.
Yeah.
The,
the first time I heard it was actually when he admitted to it,
I think I'm thinking more of,
uh,
of,
of the ax murderer.
Oh.
Vandelay and I never heard,
I never heard him say anything.
All I know is he came down from like two fucking 30 to whatever in the,
in,
in a heartbeat.
Well,
he,
there's rampage in high school.
Hold on.
Show that.
Show that again,
watch this video.
Uh,
nevermind to I take that back.
Why is that one more time?
Look how damn strong he was.
Yeah.
Rampage was just insanely strong.
If you're listening.
I'm sorry.
I don't think he was on steroids at all.
I think.
Look at that.
No,
it was so god damn strong.
It was a good wrestler too.
Yeah,
I was,
I was just,
how is that aligned to
oh sorry.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Rampage's ridiculous drawn.
If rampage use that wrestling in that physical strength and really like embraced
Jujitsu.
He liked knocking guys out but he would have been an incredible strangler.
So physically strong.
Yeah.
Cause he had the,
I mean his punching was just a,
his punching was just natural.
Yeah.
It's so hard.
Fucking fight with Randleman and the in pride.
Holy Shit.
He was terrifying back then.
Quentin rampage Jackson for people to see saw him like towards the end of his
career in the UFC.
You know,
they might judge him when he's dealing with all these injuries and you know,
it has all sorts of problems like,
and you get to really understand rampage.
You got to go back to these fights,
that pride fights.
I mean he was going over there throwing down every couple months against some of
the best guys in the world.
Fought soccer,
rob off fraud vendor lay how many times?
Twice at least.
Right.
And then he knocked out Vandelay in the UFC finally.
Yeah.
But uh,
he was such,
you know who you're reminding me of just personality wise,
not really fight wise as much.
Um,
um,
uh,
Mark Coleman.
Ah,
you know why,
why?
Because when you talk to him or he interview him,
they have no like egos are macho,
uh,
facades.
They're both fucking real about everything.
Oh,
mark home was as real as it can be.
Oh my God,
I never knew him until,
you know,
we just shot the ultimate fighter season 19.
And,
um,
I had never spent one minute with them and we spent six weeks together and this
is one of the most,
and rampage is the same way.
I remember if somebody said something after a fight once with rampage,
he goes,
well how do you feel about that decision or fighting that guy?
He goes,
are you crazy?
The guy just kicked my fucking ass.
He fucking won.
Remember that fight when there was a close fight?
He goes,
he just kicked my ass.
I don't know.
He said,
I don't know what the referees were looking at,
but I ain't got my ass whooped and,
and,
and glad against Machida.
I Dunno.
I didn't remember what you thought it was.
I remember I had never heard a guy actually say,
I don't know what the referees are looking at,
but I just got my ass whipped.
It was like,
what are you belittling the judges?
They just gave you a decision.
You're telling them they're crazy.
And,
and Mark Coleman is so much like that.
He was,
he ended up being such a real guy.
I mean,
he was like,
he was so honest about every part of his career and everything he's done and
didn't he fight?
I was getting my ass whooped.
I was so scared and that fight,
I got my shit.
They got kicked me in the head and he's just,
he was such a real guy.
I just loved Hay and these are like the real warriors,
you know?
And then they have no facades of yeah I'm a bad ass football player,
you know,
walking around or whatever.
A basketball player walking around like that.
You throw a ball through a hoop but these guys,
but these fighters are,
they have absolutely no facades.
They're just like so real.
Yeah.
We'll,
Colin was the original heavyweight champion.
He won the first UFC heavyweight title.
Yeah,
I was there.
I was very be Dan Severen submitted him,
got him in that crazy side headlock and strangle,
which he showed me that side hand rock and I couldn't,
I couldn't sleep right for like a week cause he likes to draw more of a,
or come here,
let me show you this code de Sensei,
he called me says,
let me show you this since angle.
And after he did it and he wouldn't stop.
And I was like,
okay,
I got it.
And he was like,
you feel it now in like a minute later when we let go.
Yeah,
it wasn't,
it wasn't pretty.
That was when Mark Coleman was that big and that strong.
He was making everybody gained weight.
All the USC got started just piling on the pounds.
You all saw them getting bigger and bigger because they knew eventually they're
going to have to face that fucking gorilla.
Like you couldn't fight him and look like Maury Smith.
Everybody thought he couldn't.
Like Maurice wasn't,
you know,
wasn't a big bodybuilder guy wasn't a big power lifting guy was,
in,
in shape kickboxer and everybody's like,
oh poor Maurice is fucked.
Yeah,
not so much.
Yeah.
That was one of the most shocking fights ever.
And,
and,
and mark has nothing but respect for Morrissey.
All they said was,
you know,
he basically says he was so real about that fight.
Then I guess there was that other guy that kicked him in the head.
Oh,
Pete Williams.
Yeah.
He talks about that fight and his,
his ups and downs and,
and he just has no censor about any of them.
No excuses about anything.
He just so fricking reel.
It wasn't very knowledgeable as a wrestler to McComb and knows his shit.
You know,
he'd be a really good coach.
He was a good coach and he was just,
he loved the guys and he would,
he would get,
he would just,
even though he just had a hip replacement.
Yeah,
I was going to say that it wasn't placement as teaching wrestling.
No,
he wasn't teaching wrestling.
He was wrestling,
he was doing the takedowns and getting taken down by these young,
you know,
it was two of fibers.
And they were slamming him and he was like,
you could tell you,
you can see his face sometimes,
but he,
he get up a little slower.
No,
let's do it again.
Do it a different way.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's,
he's,
he didn't know
allowed to wrestle when you have a hip replacement.
I thought those days are over.
They weren't for him.
And he's,
he's,
he's a super human.
He's,
he's,
yeah.
He's the real deal.
Placements are fucking crazy.
No,
that's a nurse.
You know,
knowing what you know,
how nutty is the idea of song off the end of your fucking femur and putting on
an artificial joint with a big steel screw and turn,
Dang,
Dang.
Getting it in with,
uh,
with,
like a,
it's like one of those railroad fricking nails that goes way into the fricking,
and then you put it with a fake,
you know,
into your bone and it's,
it's crazy shit.
And then to think he's,
you know,
competing at the level or training at the level he's training now,
you know.
Yeah.
He's a freak.
Well,
they can do that now,
man.
They,
I uh,
had,
uh,
my friend Graham Hancock was in here and he's in his sixties,
I believe.
And Graham had just got a hip replacement six weeks later he's walking around.
No problem.
No pain,
no nothing.
It's like,
what they can do now is just incredible.
It's crazy.
It's really crazy.
A lot of MMA guys like Chuck Norris apparently said hip replacements.
Yeah,
yeah.
Dan Gables all fucked up.
He's got,
you know,
huge knee issues.
I believe he's had hip replacements as well.
The Super Fund.
He had a really bad knee to begin with.
Right.
That's why you can only throw his left light.
Yeah,
it,
right.
Fascinating.
And also what a great hook,
kick kick that hasn't made it into MMA yet.
I was never good at it.
Hook,
kick.
I never knocked anybody out with a hook kick.
I never,
I never did it much in sparring.
Well,
I had spinning Hook kick and I,
you know like I threw it through a frontline roundhouse kick real fast,
but he figured out,
and Larry Kelly,
you remember Larry Kelly from Amherst,
Massachusetts.
It was a guy named Larry Kelly from Amherst,
It was famous for his hook kick.
He had this hook kick that was just like a lightning bolt and he was knocking
dude's out and karate tournaments.
He not Dell Billy blanks when Billy blanks was like a top uh,
karate points guy before Billy blanks became the Tae Bo guy.
He was like a serious point karate champion.
I know that Larry Kelly got knocked him out with a hook kick,
but I was always in awe of like hook kicks.
It's such a rare kick to see someone gets super proficient.
Yeah.
So unless you could not,
you can knock some out with a spinning hook kick or,
but a hook kick.
You can't unless you're that guy.
Cause I've never seen anyone knock out out.
Anyway.
It's more of a jab flip.
We'll super did,
didn't he?
Didn't he of some chaos with his hook kick?
I don't think so,
but he might've,
I saw him,
I don't know,
but yeah,
check them out.
But the thing about a hook kick in an MMA fight,
if you think about it with your leg up in the air like that,
you know,
you get run over a lot easier and taken down.
Oh yeah.
Where's the spinning Hook kick?
It might not land very often,
but it's pretty hard to counter as is the spinning jumped,
spinning back kick.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's interesting too,
when you see a guy like Wallace that can,
that only at the time or other could kick with one leg.
Right.
How good he got with that one leg was unbelievable.
The shit that he could do.
Well,
you don't see guys having that kind of dexterity with their kicks anymore.
And he would do a lot like this is him.
He's,
he's old as shit there,
man.
Yeah,
he's real.
Yeah.
That's nothing now.
This is,
I mean he's probably,
he's 70 years old.
60,
68 years.
I just saw him.
Yeah.
So he's still throwing hook kicks.
Benny the jet,
like Benny the jet.
He was,
he was the freakiest kickboxer ever.
I would find a young stuff,
the young videos and,
and if he could find Benny the jet spinning back kick,
it was the best ever.
He was my,
he was my trainer for years.
And you know,
he teaches right down the street at that,
uh,
this is super foot when he was,
he always fought left leg forward.
He's a good boxer too.
Yeah,
he's okay.
I traded the Jetson and when I first came to Hollywood,
when I first moved here,
Ben is teaching over there,
uh,
team karate center right there on,
in north Hollywood.
No,
it's right there on,
uh,
on,
desoto and,
and victory.
Yeah.
Benny.
It's a guy named fireball Zack.
Yeah,
it's a hop Quito school,
but they also do like a park core and they do kickboxing and Benny actually
teaches there now.
It's,
it's,
it's probably the best karate school in the valley.
Painted.
Chet had some amazing fights in Japan too.
Oh yeah.
Oh Man.
He was a tremendous kick.
Did you see his throat
when he threw the guy and ended up knocking him out with the throw and they
didn't know if they should disqualify him.
Not because frozen in Thai boxing or kind of like you're allowed to take the guy
down.
Right.
And I love to use the hip and you're not allowed to use a trip,
but you're allowed to use upper body throws.
Oh really?
He said there's a really,
uh,
the rules when they,
a lot of like in Japan,
they weren't sure about the rules here.
They're not when they,
when the,
when it's a tie match,
they don't know that there's no takedowns I go,
I remember had a rules.
He wants him.
The guy told me,
no.
Takedowns I go,
I thought this was Mu Tyrell's you're allowed to do take downs.
Just not with your hip or with your,
with your trips.
He goes,
really,
well,
let's just make it no takedowns I go.
But anyway,
Ben,
he took a guy down with a hip throw.
He was also a black belt in judo and he took the guy down and landed on him and
the guy couldn't go on cause he,
he likes Landon in his ribs and he heard his ribs so they didn't know what to
do.
So they ended up disqualifying them.
That it's a great Benny to me.
Ben,
he was the great,
the greatest kickboxer ever
and he was certainly awesome.
And he was a big time pioneer at the time.
There's money there in the red pants.
Yeah.
When I first came to Hollywood,
it's one of the coolest things when I was so happy that I could train at the jet
center.
So which one did you train it on?
Fires,
Van Nuys and the one in the fryer?
Yeah,
the one where there was all the um,
blinkies after blinky son had died and all the Mexican gang bangers,
you know,
there was so many gang bangers who were training there.
It was weird.
They were respectful.
I mean they didn't have any problem,
but it was a like a point of contention.
Yeah.
I played trained there and 94,
when I first came there,
I was already gone I think.
But uh,
but yeah,
I trained there at,
uh,
I trained there for most of my fights and it was so cool.
It was like a bowling alley that he turned into a gym.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah.
Blinkies a blinky.
Blinky is announcing now those fights that are out of China.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
He was doing,
some are announcing you sued.
See It on TV.
Every now and then we'd catch it,
some kickboxing show that they would have and he would announce some white dude.
Don't really know much.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
it wasn't.
It was it w I think now.
Is it Steve?
Uh,
who,
who else is doing it with them?
I don't know.
Ah,
I thought it was the fight doctor.
No,
no,
no.
Maybe it is now.
I don't believe it was back then.
Um,
but the,
um,
the problem with the jet center was that the earthquake fucked it up.
Oh,
it did?
It started leaking.
So when the rain came the year after the earthquake,
it just was ruining,
the gym was fucked.
So then they moved it somewhere in north Hollywood,
but then it's Sorta,
you know,
huh.
Just wasn't kind of the same situation anymore.
So he's still teaching out there.
He's still teaching out there.
Hey son,
no,
he's still teaching right there now.
And we'll then else and there's a house of champions too,
right?
Is that still around?
But that's like not his,
it's not affiliated.
Is that what it is?
The valleys.
Encino.
It how's the champions is in receipt off offshore.
Yeah.
And he wasn't,
you know,
and it's not affiliated with him per se,
but uh,
uh,
Mark Para who runs it is actually one of Benny's black belts.
And you keyed or Don?
Uh,
interesting.
Yeah.
Those,
uh,
those are the early days of martial arts man.
He's one of the real legends of the early days of martial arts,
especially in Los Angeles.
I met Benny when he came down and fun Hawaii when we had MMA,
the first MMA fights in 1976 and I fought in one and a,
I was 16,
lied about my age,
said I was 18 and I fought.
And um,
Benny was fighting as well.
So at the gym he came into our gym and I was like,
Oh,
you,
you're as part of this guy.
And uh,
it wasn't fun.
I was a 16 year old kid and he had,
he had the same spinning back kick he has now.
And he ended up knocking out some big guy named Dana Dana Goodson,
who was a 200 pound guy.
And then I ended up fighting and then so he came back and they used me to spar
with him again and he,
he told me,
if you ever come to Los Angeles,
you know,
look me up.
So I did.
And uh,
do you remember
Dennis Alexio?
Yeah.
Another Hawaiian Guy,
right?
No,
no,
it wasn't lived in Hawaii.
He lives in Hawaii and then they,
towards the end of his career and he kind of,
they throw him in with a bunch of 'em,
like they'd find guys on the beach and give them title and,
and he fought and he was a really good promoter and he wore a grass skirt in the
ring.
And he's from,
uh,
he's from Sacramento area.
Really?
Yeah.
So he just loved to,
why is that what it was?
He moved to Hawaii and they kind of adopted him and said he was a,
and he would fill that arena and it was his Blazedale Bleasdale.
Yeah.
See if you can find Dennis Alexia and the grass skirt because he would fight
with a grass skirt on.
Yeah.
It was fucking good though,
man.
He was,
yeah,
it was good.
You don't like,
you don't think it,
I don't think it was that good.
Like it's so exciting fights,
man.
Yeah.
But when,
when he fought standalone genus,
he got broken leg broken and then he,
yeah,
standalone.
Gina,
this was a really tough,
but well,
Don Wilson to Don Wilson fucked them up.
Yes.
As well as he did not like link the first guy to really fuck them up with leg
kicks was don the Dragon Wilson,
who is a really good fighter.
I got a chance to support him once.
Yeah,
it was a honor.
His sidekick was unbelievable.
His best techniques.
Fucking,
it was a sneaky dude,
man.
Really crafty fighter and a really nice guy too.
Yeah,
he's,
he's like into movies and shit now.
He did this whole series of movies.
He had a long Cynthia rothrock.
Yup.
There you go.
The point girl,
she would do like,
uh,
like those forums.
She's like a forms champion karate.
That was the blue shoe stuff,
wasn't it?
Yeah,
that was woo Shu.
Okay.
Do you ever remember a movie Khufu old old movie real?
It was like,
it wasn't even a B movie.
It's like a see movie and there's a Khufu guy,
white guy,
but he came into room and slept with this woman.
They sit up,
he goes,
get up,
get dressed,
make the bed and get out.
And she looked at him and she goes,
who do you think you're talking to?
Me like crossed his arms and gave her a mean look.
And then she goes,
would you keep the sheets?
Do you remember that movie?
No.
Me and chuck used to watch it back in the early nineties.
We,
I had the,
I had the VHS.
Right?
And we used to love,
we still make watch that movie all the time.
And then when VHS is went out,
I threw away all my VHS and I now we can't remember the name of the movie.
I'll tell ya here,
Twitter,
please tell us.
Tell him Mr Hackleman what that fucking movie get up.
I'm sure they'll tell you in five seconds.
I'm sure it will know.
There's gotta be some freak out there.
That,
so that was set to a good cause I've said that to so many women now.
Get up,
get dressed,
make the bed and get out.
How many women?
More than one?
More than one,
let's say show Alexia,
Alexia,
throwing those kicks.
He,
I probably like probably like 33 in the last,
uh,
10 years.
Yeah.
Look at him.
A crazy grass skirt and guys were complaining about that grass skirt to it.
That was back when fighting.
That's a,
that's a standard man.
Yeah.
The longe needed stopped him.
Launching either send some powerful kicks.
Yeah.
His leg just gave her no,
I had a demo.
I had an exhibition fight with a,
with a standard man awhile ago when he trained at the jet center.
Showed that again,
man.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's the first round.
He kicked hard like 10 seconds in the first round.
Broke his leg with the leg kick.
Unbelievable.
Man.
What is wrong with Youtube today?
So sucking it.
Don't tell us it's our fucking web connection.
You sons of bitches,
get up,
get dressed,
make the bed and get out.
It's one of my favorite line.
It stuck with me.
So rude to say.
Have to someone,
let you fuck him.
I know.
See this,
I heard it again.
Why is it rude?
Boom.
I was an inside leg kick if no one knows outside was outside,
but okay,
but wait,
why is it,
why isn't it?
I mean they should be honored that they slept with you.
Why is it rude?
Have you ever said it to air use John Hackleman.
That's what I have to say.
How dare that was the voice of John Hackleman saying that they should be on me.
I'm always happy when a girl says yes.
Always.
Even.
Even if it's my wife,
I have never thinking that they should be honored.
I always think that I'm the one who's honored.
Get up.
So I gotta get that says David tweet back cause you have more somber followed in
seconds,
please.
Folks.
What the fuck is it though?
Me and chuck would sit down and watch it.
That's when chick Chucky's asleep on my couch.
Do you know where Chuck's leaves now that he's had a very nice house?
Yeah,
he's not in,
he's not on the couch.
He's not an anybody's couch.
You'll never be on a couch again.
No.
Oh my God.
He said,
well that's the plan.
Right?
If he was like,
you know,
40 years old on the couch,
we would have to really think through this thing.
Then there would be no discussion with Dana.
Would be like,
yeah,
okay,
I'll retire.
I don't know.
No one's coming up with the answer.
They're fuckers.
Yeah,
we'll find it eventually.
It just might.
It's going to take a little more time than I thought it would.
Sorry.
You're obscure Kung Fu movie.
That was one of the best.
That was the one of the best.
Do you,
have you ever seen a foot fist way?
Yes.
Yeah,
it was great.
I make all my guys watch it.
All my guys,
if I had to watch a bunch of the part of the martial arts that might the pit,
they have to watch certain movies.
They have to listen to my music.
You know?
I do love really corny bad movie scenes though,
like that.
Like my favorite is from superfly.
He ever see superfly.
Superfly is one of the best bad movies of all time.
You know the movie,
right?
Yeah.
He's a drug dealer.
Ugh.
And he's,
he's in bed with this white chick and he goes,
this is all I've ever wanted.
My Hall,
my vines,
White woman,
like you zoom,
all I ever wanted,
this is America dream.
My Hall.
Meaning his car.
My vines meaning his clothes and a white girl like you.
Why is vines clothes?
Cause it's made out of plants.
You know you make your cotton is a plant civil call vines.
Yeah.
Not Silk.
Silk is made out of a plant.
It's made out of a fucking bug bug.
Pretty Weird.
Huh?
Silk Sheets.
You mean a sheet on a bug?
Shit.
How much fucking bugs do you need to make sheets?
What's this really good?
What's another good line about moving?
No,
just a movie period.
Man.
There's so many.
There's too many to begin pain.
Don't hurt roadhouse.
That's what you should show people.
Hey Sean roadhouse side.
Show him how to grab the neck.
Like just show Swayze did.
I remember when the guys he's thinking could do that.
Grab the neck and you just rip your neck out.
Fucking shitty neck.
You would have if somebody can just reach in and grab your neck and pull it out.
Yeah.
Which is crazy.
He's no longer with us.
It's hard to believe,
man.
Look at him here,
this movie,
and he's no longer with us and a big part,
ladies and gentlemen,
motherfucking cigarettes,
put those bitches down.
Yes,
he was.
He most certainly was pancreatic cancer.
So common one with cigarette smokers,
Bill Hicks,
famous comedian,
also cigarette smoker,
pancreatic cancer.
It's not a good one.
What about alkaline water?
Healthy for you,
good for you.
You drink it?
No,
I don't.
I just drink spring water most of the time.
But uh,
I think the idea of having an alkaline high diet rather than acidic diet.
I mean there's a lot of science that shows that alkalinity in your body is,
you know,
it's a good state to have and that cancer has to grow in an acidic environment.
You know,
this,
I mean,
there's so much dispute when it comes to a nutrition and health and how you
should live your life and how you shouldn't,
what kind of things are important and taking your body,
the,
the dangers or safety of Gmo foods,
you know,
there's a lot of contradicting information and articles out there.
It's really hard to get the full skinny when it comes to something as complex as
nutrition.
I think.
So do you go by,
um,
I read as much as possible on it.
Try to find what makes the most sense and then try to see like what,
how much of it has a history of use.
You know,
when it comes to like antioxidants,
when it comes to vitamins,
I mean there's a lot of shit that they know about vitamins,
vitamin supplements being,
uh,
the,
the way to stop the scurvy from coming on.
If someone's on a long boat trip and they know we're scurvy came from,
it came from a vitamin C deficiency or nutrient deficiencies and uh,
they didn't give vitamin C d today.
No.
Give Orange at the time.
Yeah,
at the time.
But you know,
they've,
they've could,
you can isolate it with vitamin C.
I mean there's,
there's ways that they've figured out to isolate essentially every vitamin and
nutrient known demand.
I mean,
this is not like,
it's not like a guest,
you know that they figured out how to get B12 they know how to get beat 12 and
if you think the beat 12 doesn't work,
it's because you've never tried be 12 be 12 for sure.
Gives you energy.
You know,
did a lot of wrestlers would take intervene as shots before matches?
Mami B12 tremendous stuff.
Ali's to be 12 yeah,
to anybody who says it's not is a silly person.
So that's proof positive right there.
You've isolated too in very unfortunate news,
important nutrients that have noticeable effects C and B 12 and that's just the
tip of the iceberg.
I mean there's a giant amount of essential fatty acids,
essential minerals that have been really proven to have a significant part in
the development of,
of,
of all sorts of aspects of your body.
Your body's essentially stardust.
I mean your body's essentially carbon and minerals and all these different
things and you need balance of these essential nutrients,
these minerals.
And if you don't have them,
osteoporosis,
what's that come from?
A deficiency of a mineral called calcium.
And there's so much of that in diet and so important and keeping the body at
optimum levels,
especially for like a pro athlete,
it's immensely significant.
Do you think you think alkaline being alkaline is more important than,
or more helpful than acid?
I don't necessarily know.
I wouldn't be able to tell you I'm not smart enough.
I'm not educated enough.
I don't know.
But I do know that there's a lot of work that I've read that where people have
studied the benefits of a high alkaline diet.
It's a lot of them.
Yeah,
there's a lot of them.
It seems to be the science is leaning towards that and that vegetables,
green leafy vegetables,
very them as well,
you know,
don't eat the same ones all the time.
There's been,
uh,
quite a few issues apparently with people who to eat kale all day,
every day.
And if you do it over long periods of time that people could develop an even
light a thyroid issues.
Keylight it.
So just make that up.
How dare you,
I know when he's joking,
at least you're not fooling me.
So what do you get?
Um,
you can,
well,
the people have had thyroid issues that are connected to a eating Kale all day,
every day for long periods of time.
And they're saying that even though it's a really healthy thing,
it can,
you know,
like,
yeah,
you need,
you need to vary your diet,
which is really kind of interesting because there's a lot of animals,
they kind of stick to one thing,
very specific type of diet and that's to avoid genetic mutation to avoid
variables that they can't control.
They know that they can eat this kind of grass.
They go and eat that kind of grass.
Like cows for instance.
I mean,
they can eat corn,
but you don't catch them eating corn anywhere else other than when people feed
them corn,
most of the time they know what the fuck to do.
Go eat the grass and he'd get bugs that you're eating in the grass as well and
you're going to get a little bit of vitamins from them and just they know what
the fuck to do.
But people,
boy,
we do better when we mix it up.
Huh?
We do better when we have a little bit of,
I am a creature of habit.
I got an Itch,
a little bit of Broccoli,
a little bit of celery,
have some cucumbers.
One day,
have a nice,
you know,
cauliflower salad the next day.
Today,
let's go with Brussel sprouts.
You know,
today,
let's have some chicken tomorrow.
Let's have some venison the next day.
Let's have some elk.
Yeah,
you'd do better when you're,
you're firing your diet.
You do a lot of home.
Not home cooked,
but yeah,
I cook a lot.
But you do a lot of,
uh,
just hunted animals,
Huh?
Well that's what I'm trying to do and my goal,
I hunt.
You're a hunter yourself.
Yes.
Yeah.
My goal is by the end of 2014,
I want to have nothing but gain me in my house.
I don't want to buy store bought meat.
I want to buy chicken and I don't want to buy steak.
I don't,
I don't want to participate in factory farming is I want to,
if I have as little participation in what I think is a bad Karma activity as
possible,
I'm not buying chicken mcnuggets you know,
I have to be really fucking starving.
I mean,
I'm not a perfect person.
If I'm in a bad situation and there's a fucking Arby's and I need some,
I need some food,
I'll eat that shit if I have to reluctantly.
But I would like it if in my home I never have to.
Hmm.
And so my goal in 2014 it's just shoot a lot of animals.
Yeah.
I got,
I got that in Montana last year.
That deer this year.
Got another one in Wisconsin.
I just got a wild pig this past weekend.
But when you go,
so when you go,
you go away.
So it's a week long trip.
The weekend,
this last time was a weekend.
I went,
went Friday night and uh,
came back Sunday morning.
And how you bring it back,
you cut it up,
cut it up and put it in the frigerator,
put it in a cooler and drive it back.
Drive it back.
Yeah.
And so I'm going to do that every few months and it'll last you a few months
each time.
It depends on how big the animal is.
His pig was huge.
It was like a 200 pound pig,
so that'll last a long time.
Um,
but I also have a venison in there still.
And uh,
I got some elk from a friend who went hunting and gave me some elk.
I got some salmon that I froze from,
uh,
last winter,
Alaska.
I didn't catch these.
These were given to me by the guide.
We,
yeah,
we were there.
There was a catch and release day.
Unfortunately when we went to go fishing,
it was like a low number and the salmon weird the day before.
So they,
sometimes they'll change it to go catch them early.
And this guy was like,
listen dude,
I got way more than enough salmon.
If you want to bring home with some wild salmon.
I got all this frozen salmon,
so he gave us like a couple of pounds of frozen salmon,
so I have some of that leftover.
That's what I want to do,
man.
I think that participating in this system where we allow people to,
to use animals as like a commodity in such a way that they try to tighten up the
bottom line so much that you,
you torture these things,
you give them these horrible existences just in order to make the maximize your
profits.
I think that's evil.
I think any company that would do that is there.
They're shortsighted,
cruel assholes,
and even though it's the standard model for these big factory farms,
I still think there's short sided,
cruel assholes and I think that shouldn't be an option.
Shouldn't be an option for humanity to stack chickens 10 on top of each other
and cut their beaks off when they're young,
to keep them from poking each other's eyes out to,
to take pigs and stuffed them into these little pens and,
and you know,
never let them roam around.
Just force feed them and pump them up for growth hormone to get them fat and
huge and then come along and kill him.
That seems disgusting.
But wild animals,
they're,
they're wild.
They're living out there as nature intended and all you do is just enter into
that world and take one out.
And
I'll never do get it from someone who's a hunter.
Find someone who,
you know,
that's a hunter that'll hook that up.
I felt bad about myself.
No,
don't feel bad,
but I could never,
I could never kill an animal if my life depend on it.
You know,
Steve [inaudible],
who's a friend of mine,
who's a famous hunter,
he has this TV show called meat eater and he was actually talking about it and
he was saying,
I don't think everybody should have to go and get food.
Just like,
I don't think that,
you know,
like people take advantage of the fact that the government or the city takes
care of your waist and we should we all be processing your own sewage to be,
keep it real.
I don't want to,
he's like,
I don't want to process my own sewage,
you know,
but I like getting my own meat so I do that.
He said,
but I'm not saying you have to and I think that's a real good way.
Right?
How would a guy and normal karate guy like me,
who's I hate,
I couldn't kill him.
I couldn't kill it.
I've never killed an animal on my,
like you eat meat,
but I love meat.
So I'm a hypocrite because I love animals,
but I eat a lot of meat.
Well,
I love animals too,
man.
I have two cats.
I have two dogs.
I love animals.
So what did,
what does a guy like me do it?
How do we find on the Internet some guy that cooks or hunts for the food.
And
I guarantee you there's someone in your area because you're in a nice area,
you're in a nice area.
It's very rural and California has a long history of hunting.
Tj Dillashaw is a hunter.
Yeah.
Chad Mendez and other guys living out there on the pit
pit.
A elevated the guy that,
you know,
that gym we have in Utah.
Yeah.
The owner of that will is a huge hundred.
He goes to Africa all the time.
Utah has a rich hunting tradition,
massive elk population,
Utah.
We were there.
One of the guys who was like a ski instructor at this place that I went to,
told me on the way to work.
He saw 20 elk,
giant bull elk just sitting on the side of the road.
I mean,
Utah Wilderness with a couple of little cities parked in the wilderness,
you know,
beautiful cities,
Salt Lake and park city.
But the fucking what surrounds it,
that's as Dank stir wilderness as it gets.
They have bears,
you know,
they have bears and elk and they have moose that wander onto ski slopes every
now and then.
And you've got to get the fuck out of the way.
You know,
a moose wanders onto your ski slope.
But I,
I mean,
we have deers by sure.
I have a property that,
but I mean,
you don't have to do it.
I guarantee you someone in your neighborhood is a hunter.
And uh,
you know,
if they,
if they hunt a lot,
they,
I'm sure they would be willing to trade some meat for some classes again.
And so I bet getting guarantee you someone in your gym who hunts would love to
give you some meat just so you could try it if you cook it right,
we'll live,
or wild game rather is some of the most delicious food you can buy or you could
have on whether you could eat so good for you.
It's so,
and it's also,
I think the most Karma free way of,
uh,
of acquiring animal meat.
If somebody hunted it and does it humanely and does it the right way,
but you know,
no,
everyone shouldn't have to do it.
Yeah,
I couldn't.
it was,
but factory farmings got to go.
We have as as a society,
even if we off to turn fucking vegetarian,
we have to stop that shit.
That's a travesty.
We're,
we're putting out so much bad energy and we're also,
when people find out about it,
it really lowers our expectations of human beings.
We find out that we're willing to do things like that to animals.
Just a profit.
It lowers what we feel like
you know,
is possible from the average person,
even already lower than we are.
I think it's one of the lowest things.
I think in other low things,
seaworld,
you know another low thing is this dolphin massacre that they're about to do.
You see that shit.
They have like two and the place where they filmed that movie,
the cove,
they've trapped 250 dolphins in there now and they're gonna slaughter him and
everybody knows about it is not in any way we can do about it.
That I think that's,
that lowers our,
our expectations of human beings lowers our,
our,
our possibilities.
It changes our range.
You know what we look,
what's normal was this is murdering dolphins normal in my world and your world.
The fuck it is.
If everybody was John Hackleman or me,
there'd be no murder of dolphins.
Right?
Or drones or drones or bicycle riders on the street.
Fuck bicycle riders and what's true?
Writers that smoke outside of Starbucks cigarettes.
How about people that throw cigarettes out there?
Fucking windows,
those Jack Offs.
I like to just pull them over and beat the shit out of him.
I'd like to see you do it now.
Or smokers this watch him in the arm so hard that they can't lift their hands up
to them to smoke.
Don't knock them out.
You don't have to give a head trauma.
Just hold them down and just beat their delts up.
Just pound knuckles right into their shoulders on both sides so that you
literally can't smoke.
I mean,
why would somebody smoke when you have to inhale it?
Well,
because they get caught.
They got caught by the cool bug.
It's happened to a lot of people that are very intelligent that I know.
Have you ever asked anyone to,
to put down to Sierra?
Sure,
yes.
They get to see people get angry.
You know,
it's,
it's an interesting thing.
They don't mind littering,
you know,
people that uh,
he's telling me it's 10 minutes left.
People like when they go,
um,
to uh,
uh,
restaurants and they have like outside seating.
I saw this woman smoking,
she was on the phone smoking and then just putting her cigarette out in this
plant.
You know,
this like big,
beautiful Bush and have a little pot,
a big potter wheel,
you know,
a big,
a potter,
a,
you know,
uh,
plant potting thing.
She just sticking her cigarettes and they're just poking out like little trees.
She had four cigarettes in there while she was on having a little conversation.
I was like,
this is disgusting.
You're a gross.
Litterer like if you took a soda can and threw it in there,
would that be okay?
No,
it wouldn't be,
but you think it's okay to take your fucking gross cigarettes and stick them in
the dirt?
Yeah,
it's a disgusting habit.
If it's disgusting.
I,
I've,
you know,
I bought for smokers is because I've,
I,
it's one of my pet peeves then I've asked them if I'm anywhere and I smelled
smoke,
I'll ask him to put it out.
And most people are really obliging,
but there's people that haven't been,
I just think what can I do to get Ethan?
I mean these guys pissed me the fuck off.
I can't spit on him getting in trouble.
So I buy fart spray and a,
I got fart spray online and I'm not proud of it.
Um,
but,
but I remember,
and I remember the first time I did it,
it backfired cause I was actually at my favorite character bar cause I'm
probably one of the best karaoke singers of all time probably.
But say
I asked her to please not smoke outs,
you know,
it's,
I'll smoke wherever the fuck I want.
So I said okay.
So I took on my first spray and I sprayed her.
Okay,
now this thing is hard.
I don't know if you were a small as far,
it's pretty,
but it's hard.
And I thought I got even with her.
So I walked back in the bar,
she was too drunk to even know it and she ended up coming back in the bar.
So I had to leave the bar because this farts smell was worse than the cigarette
smoke.
So that was my Karma.
Yeah,
I got it turned around on you.
it was a bitch.
Yeah.
The cigarette thing,
people don't think of it as an imposition on anyone but themselves.
So there'll be outside in front of a place like the opening of a restaurant or
whatever and just to be sitting there smoking and you're inside the restaurant
and it comes in,
you're like,
oh,
it's disgusting.
And it's just someone outside the exit door,
like they don't realize it smells when you're smoking.
Things are real weird.
Like weed as another example.
Like people don't realize that we'd stink so bad when you're smelling like they
don't know that other people could smell it because there's something that's
happening when you're smoking weed.
We don't really smell it that much.
But if you walk into a room and people have been smoking weed,
you like Jesus fucking Christ.
Do you guys know what this place smells like with the people in it?
Don't seem to have a grasp on it.
They don't,
you're,
you're all factory sensors.
Detect changes in smell.
They don't necessarily detect smells
and I don't find it as is.
Uh,
I don't find it as a offensive weed.
Smoking.
It smells good.
It's like cigars smelled good too.
Who are pipes?
Yes.
Pipe smoke.
Great.
Like the Nice Cherry tobacco or something like that.
I love it.
That's good.
My pop,
my Stepdad was a big pot smoker.
Yeah.
From the time he was a musician,
played in a Bangladesh.
I mean he was a musician,
a working musician his whole life.
And uh,
here's a dude,
Larry Kelly knocking out Billy blanks with a head kick.
Watch this.
Oh,
cake.
It's pretty sweet.
He was a really good at it.
Oh,
Pretty Nice,
Huh?
Yeah.
Guy had a hell of a hook kick.
You always heard about it.
That's a good hint.
But not that often.
You don't see that in UFC.
But that would work.
Maybe if it worked there,
it would work.
Right.
Because he was moving back.
But can you imagine if he threw it while a wrestler was coming in?
He would get taken down for a show so that would worry fought in white tie guy
and the guy goes underneath it and a tax that the supporting leg and the way he
threw it was almost,
we put his hip forward so it was almost like he was throwing a spinning hook
kick cause he got it a hip into of a,
most guys that throw it just bring their back,
their,
their leg back.
So it's not with that much power.
That one.
Yeah.
Let me see the way he throws,
he comes back,
he's going to bring his hip forward,
see how he brought us,
hit forward and then came back.
So we get that hip into it.
It'd be like throwing a jab up here,
but then you bring your hand back and forth the jab so it's more like a right
hand.
That was a nice one though.
Yeah.
He's uh,
he's a,
he was a talented motherfucker.
Yeah.
Okay.
Jerry tremble.
Yeah,
Jerry Trauma.
I met Jerry Tremble when a,
I was working somewhere in like Santa Clarita and Jerry Trimble just happened to
be on the same set doing something completely different.
I got a chance to say hi to him.
He has,
he has the best,
um,
highlight video on youtube.
Really.
Jerry tremble.
He was a hell of a fighter.
Yeah.
And he just has,
his is a dynamic way and his personality,
his highlight video is actually my favorite fight.
Highlight video of anyone there is where there it is.
Ooh.
Yeah.
His highlight video was,
oh yeah,
Jesus.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker in the PKA days.
He was one of the few guys that was like super good.
Yeah.
And really fun to watch together like Benny did.
Because there was a lot of,
the public of this three 60 roundhouse kicked out.
He was a lot of people in those pka days that were really boring,
stinking point.
Point point,
yeah.
Well not just that,
like they would throw kicks just cause they had to have a minimum amount of
kicks.
Yeah.
So they would throw these like halfassed kicks just to get their minimum men and
then there was guys like trembled there at all these wild techniques.
Yeah.
Damn.
He was a bad motherfucker.
Sean,
you've Terrio you remember him?
Yes,
I do.
He will.
Who?
Blinky Rodriguez knocked out.
Yeah,
he was good.
But he didn't do the leg kick.
No.
Terrio a was above the waist guy lost when he did do the leg kicks,
right?
Yeah.
He's from Toronto.
And that's to WHO's beat him up,
didn't he?
I Dunno,
but I know he's from Toronto.
Yeah,
you have the lake,
the non lake kit guys.
When they came over to light kick,
they just,
uh,
it was like a,
it was like a boxer trying to fight a wrestler guy.
Yeah.
He just,
they could not cope with it.
Like see Cherry Trump out of the best,
uh,
highlight.
He's,
he has actually had an MMA guys and anyone else.
He has my favorite highlight video of all time really.
And I don't even know him.
I just happened to be,
I just saw it once.
I was like,
this is my favorite.
And I wrote in the comments,
this is my favorite or something.
And he thanked me for it.
But that's awesome.
Yeah.
He's,
that's,
he's uh,
he's an awesome guy.
Yeah.
Those,
uh,
it's,
it's really interesting because those guys from that era there that,
that is responsible for like holding kickboxing back a little bit for some
reason.
The PKA.
Yeah.
I was wk.
Oh,
you were Wko.
Yeah,
we fly wk.
So we did like cakes and then some sometimes needs to,
and then,
uh,
that was Benny system,
you know,
that's what he liked,
wk and,
and uh,
they had PK and then,
um,
and like I said in Hawaii we kind of had to know commission thing,
so we just kind of fought any system.
Yeah.
That must've been a really nutty time.
Huh.
It's crazy.
I loved it.
I hate,
I hated growing up in Hawaii,
but uh,
but I loved,
uh,
I loved the fight,
the fight fighting in Hawaii.
She,
they have some really good fighters in Hawaii and there's some really good ones
coming up to right now.
Well,
I'm always has been,
you know what I mean?
To think about like the,
the,
just the tradition of bad motherfuckers from Hawaii.
So from Bj Penn was not the first,
but no,
certainly signifies,
it symbolizes
that style of a,
a fighter.
Well,
this brown other proud Hawaiian.
Scary fucking dude,
man.
He is,
he's a beast that those elbows that he does when guys are holding on to that
single holy shit.
He generates a lot of power with those.
Yeah.
They have some Hawaii.
Hawaii has always been a fight.
Culter a lot.
There's been a lot of fights in Hawaii.
I mean,
the first MMA fight was in Hawaii.
I should,
I should correct myself.
He lost his John Eve Terrio who,
uh,
Ernesto hoost.
He didn't beat Sean.
You've Tara.
They fought it blinky.
Okay.
Waste.
Oh,
okay.
That's an ESCO.
Who's,
yeah,
they fought above the waist.
They sh they fought Johnny [inaudible] style and then,
uh,
he fought.
Uh,
he's,
he's funny.
Everybody,
man.
He fought.
Rob came in last,
it came in and he lost to a John,
you've Terrio again later on in his career.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Rick Rufus and another one.
Duke's products rather.
It was a bad motherfucker in those days.
He was in one of the other really exciting guys and the PK days.
Yeah.
But he had a good transition over to two leg kick kickboxing as well.
I think we're,
I think Duke was better,
but yeah.
More successful.
That style of fighting.
Yeah.
But he was,
he definitely had his day.
The other jet.
Yeah.
Well Rick,
the jet,
Rufus was a fan of Benny the jet,
so he took his nickname.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean that's where,
that's where he got the nickname.
He got the nickname cause he's a Benny the jet fan.
A huge fan of Benny's.
Yeah.
Well Ben,
he was like one of the original pioneers.
He was,
yeah,
he,
yeah.
And he's still,
he's still teaching.
He's still,
he's still hanging in there.
He said he was the free kind of guy that just could do everything.
I mean he could stand right in front of you two inches from your face,
jump up in there and do a spinning back kick.
Yeah.
Wow.
Good old days.
My friend,
those are the good old days.
A lot of good old days coming up still today will be the good old days one day.
So you've got a lot of good like,
yeah,
I mean there's,
there are some great guys coming up and uh,
I got guys like court coming in and,
and Glover making it to the top.
What's this an exciting time for MMA?
You know,
it's,
it's still in its infancy.
It was crazy as it sounds,
it's still,
I mean when there's a 10 20 year history from now,
from now to today,
people are going to look back at these times like,
well this is like when it was really starting to explode from there.
It'll be the biggest sport in the world.
What do you think it can be changing?
Like it's changed from boxing?
It's a good question.
Um,
this is always going to be,
I think once.
What do you think is the dumbest rule that they should change?
12 to six elbows.
12 to six elbows are crazy.
It doesn't make any sense.
As my last blog,
did you write it about 12 to six elbows 12 and six or three to nine.
Stupid.
Well,
Travis Brown and um,
the,
the reunite the Josh Barnett one.
That's okay because it's three to nine.
This is so fucking stupid kindie punches.
It's all of it's so stupid.
Skinny punches are stupid too.
That's a stupid rule.
You can't kick the kidneys when you're on the bottom.
When you're uh,
in the guys guard.
That's an effective technique,
man.
Yeah,
you should allow that.
If you could throw a body kick,
you're kicking the kidneys,
man.
If you're kicking a guy on his left side,
you're kicking his fucking kidneys.
Have you hit him on his right side?
You're hitting him in his liver.
It's legal.
It should be illegal.
Well,
the liver,
you can hit the liver because the liver is in the front.
Right?
And there's only one.
Yeah.
And you can't live without it.
Right in the kidneys there's two of them.
And there you can live without them.
I mean,
you'd have to be on dialysis,
but there's two of them,
so you could live with one just fine,
but you can't kick the kidney,
but you can kick the liver and you can can hit the brain.
That's pretty sensitive.
One,
two most sensitive one period,
the most important one or irreplaceable and you're,
you're,
you're actually,
they want you to hit it as hard as you can.
If we got to wrap this up at three o'clock we turn into a pumpkin or three hours
in.
All right,
so we are three hours in.
Oh my God,
it's over.
I thought I was worrying,
thinking.
Now that time I want to keep you not stopping now get up,
get dressed,
make the bed and get the fuck out and we can do it again.
We'll do it again in the future.
We could easily see,
I knew that it would be easy,
like the conversations,
the conversations that I've had with you in the past,
I knew it would be easy to do three hour things like that.
There's stuff I wasn't,
I didn't talk about yet.
Do you have anything really important to mom?
Is she write all that down?
What about sodomy?
Sunday?
We have not talked to us about that anymore.
They've changed that rule.
How does the Monday people want to get ahold of you?
Uh,
on Twitter it's a,
he has a,
it's not,
don't look for under John Hackleman because some fucking fakers out there.
Look for Pitt.
Underscore master pitmaster is John Hackleman.
Do you,
do you respond to Twitter?
I love Twitter shit and I'm on it.
I love it.
It's,
it's,
it's one of my favorite tools.
Pit underscore master.
Please.
Uh,
please hit me up on Twitter.
Pit underscore master.
Thank you brother.
It was a lot of fun man.
I really enjoyed it.
I appreciate you coming over.
I feel fat and do it again.
We're going to do it again.
Three hours we flew by.
All right,
see you later.
It was fun.
Thank you to lumosity.com go to lumosity.com forward slash click on the star
training button.
I play your first game,
thanks to onnit.com and loves the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all
supplements.
John Hackleman much respect my brother.
Thank you very much.
All right.
We'll be back tomorrow with any kickass economist.
Peter Schiff.
He had Johnny Hackleman,
Johnny,
Johnny Hackleman go,
Johnny Hackleman much luck and yeah,
we'll be back tomorrow with Peter Schiff so,
well,
we'll find out how the world works.
I don't understand it.
Hopefully you will.
We'll see ya.
Big Kiss.